You guys want to change it to two?
Ready?
I don't know. Brenda, I'm ready. I don't
know if I'm ready as well. Okay.
Welcome to the June 11th, 2025 full
board meeting of Manhattan Community
Board 6. My name is Sandy McKe and I am
the chair of CB6. This meeting is called
to order at 7:04 p.m. Tonight we are
joined by First Vice Chair John Keller,
Secretary Justin Goldberg, District
Manager Jesus Perez, Assistant District
Manager Brendan Burth, and community
coordinator Brian Laferty. We observe
the following ground rules. No one may
speak until granted the floor. Please
raise your hand and wait for me to
recognize you. Then you can make your
motion or comment. Members of the
public, if you wish to give remarks
during the public session and have not
already registered by filling out a
form, you can register to speak in the p
in this session um by filling out the
form.
This must be done by 7:15 or by using
the Q&A feature of Zoom and posting your
name, your affiliation, and what
specific topic you wish to speak about.
The agenda for tonight's meeting was
distributed ahead of time by the board
office, was posted online, and appears
on the screen before you. If there is no
objection, we will adopt the agenda as
stated. Board members, if you object to
adopting the agenda, you may raise your
hand.
Seeing no objections, the agenda for
tonight's meeting is adopted. Justin
Goldberg will now take attendance by
roll call.
We will now
turn it on.
We will now take attendance by roll
call. Board members, when your name is
called, please say present. Yes. Tanya
Aries, present. Kyle, hi.
I don't see him. Neil Barklay.
Martin Barrett.
Oh.
Elie Barroso
not present.
Daniel Bernstein
Liz Bur.
You see her? I don't see No, I see her
on Zoom.
Still present. Liz Burr present.
Thank you. Jim Gins here. Stuart Desert.
Beatatric Disman present.
Maya Donahghue. Robert Fairfan
Freriedman present. Jason Fromitz. Eric
Goldberg. Justin Goldberg present.
Gloria Hage present. Rabia Hickfall
present. Paige Judge.
Paige judge.
I don't see her. It says disability.
Okay. See Rupaul Kakad here. John
Keller. Kate Kennedy present. Nadine
Khani.
Not here. Katie Lamba present. Sandre
Ltoff present. David Levy present.
Anton Molner present. Sandra McKe
present. Alec Militic present. Richard
Mintz present. Kevin O'Keefe
not here. Not here. Rashma Patel
not here. Not here. Steven Perez.
Will Perry
Omar Kashi
not here. Miam Ralph. Michael Anroe
present.
Lauren Sh
uh president from the emergency room at
NYU Langon.
That's commitment there.
Three hours. That's
usually the emergency room happens after
the meeting.
I was stressed out about Okay. An
Seligman not here. Not here. Sand
Sherrod not here.
The rest of the list. That's it. There's
more. Yeah, a few more. Uh, Rabine
Sadiki present. Letty Simon present.
Mark Thompson present.
Gabriel Tzo,
Papuero,
James Verro, present. Jerry Weinstein,
present. Sarah Whittington,
David Woods,
um, Shia Zhao.
All right, with 32 members duly present,
we do have Orum.
The elected officials have sent their
reports ahead of time and you can find
them on the CB6 website. They can be
found in the chat on Zoom or on the
board's website page for full board
meetings. I've asked our elected
officials to be brief or wave their
reports this evening due to the large
number of people who have signed up to
speak in the public session this
evening. But first up, we have Arfan
Karim from Belleview Hospital. He is
Belleview Hospital's chief clinical
officer here to talk us about what's
happening at Belleview.
Microphones I guess over there.
Is it working or you can come here? Come
here.
This is Thank you for having me um for
the chief operations officer at New York
City Health and Hospitals Belleview. Um
I am excited to come talk to you about
updates uh about our hospital which is
just across the street or across the
room fair that's um here. Um and I
wanted to let you know that Belleview is
doing well and we are u here for the
community here for every one of you and
everyone in our community who serve it.
As you probably already know Belleview
is the oldest municipal hospital in the
country that actually predates the
country. We're celebrating our 289th
year founded in 1736.
And um as you know, we've been through
fever. Um we've been through the HIV
epidemic. We've been through uh
significantly other special pathogens
including Ebola where we had the only
patient um who walked out of the
building uh almost 10 years ago now uh
Dr. Craig Spencer and most recently CO
19. Um we serve the community and the
city uh valiantly in in trying to
protect um and that legacy continues
today, right? Belle is here uh and
Bellev will be here 300 and more years,
right, to serve the community and to
make sure that we're the beacon um when
there's time of need. Um few updates
from the last several months. Um, as um,
you might not know, we celebrated nurses
week. Um, we celebrate all of our
wonderful nurses who take care of the
patients day in day out. Um, and that
was special cuz, you know, it's a way to
recognize our nurses. It's a way to
build a community uh, and to make sure
that um, the heart of our uh, service is
um, the wellness factor is taking into
um, effect. Um we celebrated our
children's author who donated um our
painter that donated works of art um and
it to make the space more lively uh and
to make sure that our anger's patients
are taking care of um you know with
provided with color and comfort and joy
uh that they deserve. And then uh
throughout May um we um we celebrated or
we recognized breast cancer um awareness
month um and we organized series of
mamograph signup events throughout
Mother's Day. Um they were designed to
encourage staff and community members to
prioritize with their help through early
detection and preventive u measures. Um
you also probably know we're the only
level one trauma center below uh 68th
Street, right? But whenever there is an
emergency or trauma or things that
happen, uh those patients usually come
to Belleview. Uh that included um uh the
ship that had an accident, right? um
recently the Mexican consulate um we
took care of all patients from that
event um at Belleview um our staff was
there for them and we made sure that
everybody's taken care of um few things
that I want to talk about uh that is
important in continuing this legacy and
to make sure that we take care of our
patients. The first is, as you probably
know, um there is a bill that passed in
Congress um that might cut Medicaid
dollars uh significantly and that will
have a significant impact not only
Belleview but rest of health and
hospitals and safety net system
throughout the country. Um it is
something that um we're uh very much u
observing and worried about because 70%
of our patients are Medicaid patients,
right? Um we're here for everyone that
comes through the door. We take care of
every single patient irrespective of the
ability to pay and we will continue to
do so. But this makes it harder. So we
encourage community members to reach out
to the electeds to other community
members. Build awareness of how
important Medicaid uh and Medicare is to
the health system and how important it
is for those services to uh remain at
the current level if not increase.
Right. Uh definitely a cut is not
warranted. Um from a personal level I
can tell you um so I I'm a first
generation immigrant. I grew up in
Queens in Sunnyside Queens across the
river. Um and my family was served by
health and hospitals. I went to Almer my
whole life, right? My parents still get
care there. Um and you know at different
points my parents had multiple jobs.
They juggled different things and health
and hospitals was there and Medicaid and
Medicaid like programs is what helped us
get through and for me to be successful.
Um, so health care is a human right.
Health care is something that's a
necessity and it's an economic engine
for everyone, right? Um, it allows
people to work, allows for them to be
healthy and be productive in the
community. And without Medicaid and
without um health
awareness and health availability, it's
going to be very difficult. So, I
encourage everyone to continue um to
challenge that um bill that's out there.
Um, there's still time. It only passed
one side of Congress. it still needs to
go through Senate and everything else.
So, uh please definitely um ensure that
you're doing everything you can uh to
help L's sustain itself, right? And help
the hospital sustain itself. The last
thing um I wanted to talk about and I
know everyone's interested in it. So,
recently in our community, a hospital
closed down right on Israel. Um and um
we at Belleview, you know, responded
swiftly and effectively uh to deploy
Israel. Um we took proactive measures to
expand that capacity and safe continued
care for our community. Um so we we made
sure we're there just like we've been
there. We'll always be there and we're
ready to take care of the patients. Um
you know, it's um the timing was helpful
in some ways. It's a coincidence that um
there was a slight change in FDY
ambulance run. So there was a slight
decrease in that week that on Saturday
night that Israel closed. Um and so it
allowed us to kind of um understand the
flow and get ourselves up to speed. Uh
but quickly um once that was um um fixed
or changed um the volume returned to
more the baseline um we are seeing
additional um EMS runs. We're also um
seeing you know market increase in
walk-in patients as expected right
patients are coming for their care um
the demand has contributed to higher
admission rates so more people are
coming into our acute hospital and the
inpatient units we also see um increase
in our psychiatric uh emergency uh
department right the CPAP program has
seen extra uh patients come in um the
third things that we are um monitoring
because those admissions leads to, you
know, more patients in house. That means
we need uh we need to make sure that
we're doing our part to be efficient,
but at the same time, we continue to
grow and meet the demands of of the
community. Uh so we're we're we're
really working hard at Belleview and
working smart to make sure that we're
able to address all needs, right? Uh one
example of a need, you know, heart
attacks and strokes, we hear about this
all all the time, right? Uh particularly
when it comes to strokes um time is
everything. Every second, every minute
counts. Um as you probably know. So when
a patient is brought to our emergency
department, we have to act very quickly.
Um and in stroke care, uh radiology
equipment is very important because you
want to know where exactly the stroke is
um what's happening and you want to get
that done quickly. Um so as um a as
those events happen uh you know our
equipment being up todate is equally
important and so we're encouraging you
know and advocating for uh those
equipments right up making those
equipments up to date. Some of our
equipments are 20 years old when the
life cycle might be 7 to 10 years right
their end of life. Um we want to replace
them with more modern equipment. We want
to increase our capacity to do more um
exams um and we want to be able to treat
our patients right in the case of a
stroke um with using those equipments.
Um these are called single plane and
biplane. They're uh technical things but
essentially um a physician could go in
uh and take out that clock, right? Clog
um like it's like unclogging your drain,
right? they go plumbing um and that
literally leads to um our patients
walking out the door, right? Uh somebody
who might be incapacitated will not be
because of these tools. So we are
definitely um encouraging our electeds
as well as our community to advocate for
those end of life equipment to be um
built so that we could continue to treat
our patients. Um and then we're
continually working in our ED and other
areas um within the budget that we have
with the agreement we have with Mount
Sinai to make sure that we're using our
public dollars um effectively, right? Uh
and prudently. Um we will increase our
CT capacity in the ED. Uh we're we're
also uh working on um making sure the
flow um is adequate and it's going
through.
That's um essentially my um update for
Belleview. Um, and um, happy to take
questions if we're really hoping we
don't have any questions this evening.
We do have a health committee that I'm
happy to have people attend. It meets
tomorrow night, but thank you very much.
We we really want to know what's
happening in our community and please
come to come visit us. Um, we have a
wonderful campus. You don't have to just
come from medical care. You have to come
in. We we have lots of architecture. at
the old building, but you know, you
never know uh if you have to go there.
So, just uh come chance and take a look
and then uh if you ever need medical
care, I promise you we're going to give
you top-notch care.
I just have to say thank you for the
immunizations.
I really appreciate it.
Those are the really important
preventive care is the number one way of
not going to be for emergency payment,
right?
That's another thing to advocate for in
these times where you know that's under
attack, but um we're here and we'll
always be here. Thank you again. Thank
you very much.
Um so next up we have Assembly Member
Harvey Estee. He's on Zoom this evening.
Yes, Andy. Here I am on Zoom. We're
still in Albany. So, you know, we have
about five days left in the legislative
session. So, but I wanted to just
quickly I know you guys got a long
meeting in my in my monthly report. We
spent a lot of time talking about the
budget that we passed last month. Even
though it was late, we did pass. There's
a lot of good things in that, you know,
talking about funding issues. We care
about things that we were fighting for
like uh the housing access voucher
program, which is basically state-based
section 8 program. talking about money
for uh abortion training to get more
doctors trained. You know, a lot of
things about funding, a lot of money for
public safety and mental health, trying
to create a new 911 system across the
state like Rochester has what's called
Daniel's law. Really trying to talk
about the issues that are affecting all
of us in New York City around public
safety, mental health, and affordable
housing. Not to mention, we did around
arts and cultures, environmental money,
and a lot of money going back to
individuals in New York. a lot of bills
that people at some other time you want
to talk to me about legislation that
we're doing a lot. We uh we have a
shredding event with Senator Gonzalez
and I July one if people want to shred.
We just had one last week but on my
district office we're doing this one in
in Sty Park neighbors associations
co-sponsoring it. If you uh want to come
down obviously everyone needs to shred
including me. Um it's really important
and just really if people have things
that they want to get done before the
legislative session the Senate is
leaving tomorrow. We are here probably
till Tuesday for the last moment. things
that we're trying to get done like
reducing waste and extended producing
responsibility, talking about the New
York Heat Act. They're trying to get
some really important environmental
bills done as well as we're doing a
whole package on people know about the
death of Robert Brooks and we're doing a
package of bills around criminal justice
reform. I'm attending my community board
meeting and we hear you. So that's
Larry, we hear you. Um uh so you know
please do reach out. I know you got a
bill packed meeting. I know Sandy
doesn't want anyone to ask any questions
but I'm happy to talk to you or send me
an email or if you're really dying to
ask me a question. I'm sure Sandy might
let you. But if not, you know, I'm I'm
available when you want to talk. Great.
Thank you. Um we will we will take
questions after after after if anybody
has them. But thank you very much. All
right, everyone. I'm going back to the
legislative session. Thank you. Take
care. Byebye.
Uh, next up we have Payton Schultice
from Kenn Senator Gonzalez's office.
Hi. Hi. I have anything to add to my
report. I'll take any questions, but
I'll leave that up to you.
Great. Thank you.
Next, please have Wendy Brennan from
Senator Krueger's office.
Hey, I just wanted to announce that I'm
taking um over CB6 from Justin and I
know you have a long agenda and I will
come in person the next time and hope to
get to meet some of the board members.
Thank you. Bye. Great. Thank you. And
say goodbye to Justin for us. He's been
great. Um next we'll have Brocca
Rosenberg from BP Lavine's office.
Burough President Lavine.
Hi. Um I'll just say read my report.
don't want to take up any more time.
Great.
Um, we have a question for you from
Jason. Oh, I'll take that. Thank you.
Um, this evening we're going to be
talking about a busway uh on 34th
Street. Uh, I understand there uh was a
some communication relayed from the
Burough President's Office uh about
about that about the third opinion on
the 34th Street bus. Yeah, I believe
there was a letter um uh together with
Keith P's office. Um so I I I mean I
would defer to them because they took
the lead on that. Um but we we were on
board as well um in support of the bus
way. Okay. Thank you. Great. Thank you.
Okay. Um Michael Anne, you have a
question.
Uh yeah, I was going to ask a question
too about the 34th Street busway. Um and
like it's interesting how you queued
that up, Jason. Um where was there a
survey? Do you have a survey to to
provide for us of of community
engagement on such a massive project?
Um I don't have that for you. Um but I I
will um I will also defer perhaps uh
Keith P's office can speak more to the
community engagement piece. Um I or or
someone from our policy team I can I can
look back on to that as well. Yeah.
Because the community doesn't Thank you.
Okay. Okay. Um, next we're going on to
uh any other questions? No. Community
board. David Lawrence.
David Lawrence. What is your question
for the Burough President's Office? Yes.
If if Miss Rosenberg can ensure that the
Burough President has access to all
relevant traffic data concerning that
proposal.
Um, yes. I mean, I believe our
transportation uh policy analyst is is
very on top of all of that. Okay.
Because when we had the meeting the
other week, DOT did not have that data.
So, if you could follow I don't know
exactly. Yes. I again I I would have to
defer to the expert in my office, but I
I will definitely check in with them.
Okay. Thank you,
Charlotte Fan. Uh what is your question
for the Burough President's Office?
Charlotte fan. We will have Hello. Uh
it's Will and Charlotte. Hi. Um uh we we
were just curious as to how um uh the uh
exit uh from the U tunnel uh would um be
diverted in the south direction.
Overall, I think that I'm also in
support of the bus way. I mean, I think
I'm not sure that the burough president
has the answer to that question. It's a
little bit too detailed. Okay. Thank
you, though. Okay. Um, if there are no
other questions, we'll move on to Robin,
excuse me, Robin Forest from the mayor's
office. Hi, everybody. I too will be
brief. I want to make a quick
announcement. Um the late um Congressman
Charlie Wrangle uh will be lying in
state at city hall tomorrow between the
hours of 9 and 5. The there's a viewing
available to the public if anybody would
like to attend. The funeral service is
on Friday at St. Patrick's Cathedral.
And with that, I'll talk more next time.
Thank you. Thank you. Mackie Bentley,
who is here in person from Congressman
Nadler's office.
Hello everyone. One thing from the board
real quick. Uh Congressman Nadler, state
senator screw will be holding a town
hall next Tuesday, June 17th from 6:00
to 7:30. They will be moderating special
guest
online. Thank you so much. And um
okay. And I believe um David Lawrence,
are you is your hand still raised or did
you have a question a new question? Just
for reasons for efficiency, could we
just ask every representative of the
elected officials, state as well as
city, including the representative from
the mayor's office to ensure that they
have all relevant traffic data from the
department of transportation covering
this proposal and any analyses and
assessment that's been done. and if
there's a way to report back to the
members uh of the community board what
studies have been done and that there is
data that has actually been assessed and
fully assessed independently I think
that would be very helpful. So rather
than raise my hand each time if I can
just make that request of every elected
city state official. Thank you.
Certainly we will make sure we we uh
transmit that to them. Okay. Um, uh,
after Maki,
I'm sorry, Michael, did you have a
question for Maki? Yeah, just real
quick, what town hall meeting? What's
the town hall meeting about? On the 17th
town hall, just a general town hall in
Hunter College. Um, if there
you can register online, Michael. Yes,
you can register online.
And so you have a question for Maki. Is
it possible to increase the volume?
Uh the volume of me or the volume of
as it goes.
Okay. Hopefully that's better.
Um, next we have Emma Johnson from
Council Member P's office.
Hello everybody. Um, my name is Emma. I
am uh standing in for Pat this evening.
He is out on vacation this week. So, I
know there's a lot of questions about
the the 34th Street bus. I think I I may
not be the best person for it, but I am
happy to take all of those questions
back to the council member and to our
chief of staff, Ben, and uh we can
continue talking after the meeting. I
will I'll skip a couple of the other
things that I was going to talk about,
but I did want to mention that we have a
couple of events coming up. I want to
make sure everyone's aware of. Number
one, they're both on the same day.
They're on June 21st. Number one is uh
we're doing an adoption event uh
co-sponsored with the Animal Care
Centers of New York. That's going to be
in Madison Square Park. That's 11:30 to
4:30. And then the same day, June 21st,
we're also going to be doing a shred
event and it's going to be right in your
neighborhood, uh, right at Sutton Place.
So, it's in the little, uh, culde-sac on
East 57th Street and Set in Place. And
that's going to be 10:00 a.m. to 1:00
p.m. So, again, those are on the same
day, June 21st. So, I'll skip the rest
of the um, everything else I had in my
report, but I'm I'm happy to uh, take
questions back to the team about the
34th Street Bus because I know a lot of
people have questions about that.
Right. Okay. Thank you. Do we have any
Yes. info. Does she have the info? Can
we get it? Right. She said that they
know the letter with the office but ours
took the lead. So, do they And I think
the question is from the from the
audience here is do you have information
on the um on the data for the busway?
I don't have uh data that I can share
with you. I I think that would be coming
from DOT, but I'm I'm happy to uh bring
that back to the rest of the team and
see what we can get for you. What do you
have? Thank you.
I'm sorry. Do we have a question here?
Please, if you do raise your hand, I
can't I can't. And um if you could speak
quite loudly so not a problem.
Can you hear me? Said that they did a
letter with powers and that they had the
data. That's why they did the letter
with powers. How come she's saying she
doesn't have the data? I believe she's
saying she's not the person with the
data. So, I I um
I Yeah, like I like I mentioned, I um I
think Pat will know a little bit more
about this than I do, but I I am happy
to uh ask the rest of our team to get
some of that data for you. I I think Are
you asking specifically about a traffic
study? Um I'm asking about everything to
do with the bus. I want to know how many
cars come in from each tunnel. I want to
know where they go. I want to know how
many express buses. I want to know how
many Excuse me, ma'am. Please. We
understand you'd like full data. Thank
you. Thank you. All of it. All of it.
Okay. We don't have it right now. So,
unfortunately, wait until it's actually
34 Street bus before we speak about it.
Yes, please.
Uh there's a gentleman back here who
still has his hand up.
about that data, miss last week, thieves
said during this very issue that the
data was incoming complete and not done
yet and I was wondering if that data has
since been completed and then you
couldn't really talk about it because we
seem complete. Um, I don't believe this
particular person was at that meeting.
No, it's not.
Okay. Thank you. We understand that
you're looking for the data. We will ask
for it um and we can move on. Thank you.
A quickie. I have a quickie. Just I just
Okay.
Yes. Um, can you hear me? I just want to
make sure you can hear. Yes, we can.
Okay, great. Um, I just wanted to check
from the last meeting. I didn't catch
how long have you been doing this
research, looking for this data, trying
to collect the data.
Is that a question for me? Yes. Uh, so
we uh I mean again this is data that
would be coming from DOT. So our office
is not conducting a study. Uh so it's
it's not something that I have been
updated about a status of a a study or
um the data that you all are looking
for. So I I'm I wish I had more to tell
you. I don't know the status of it, but
I'm I'm happy to ask Ben and Pat who you
all know. Um Pat is back in the office
next week. Uh so I'm I'm happy to bring
that to the both of them and see what I
can get from them. And we'd like to move
on, please. I see Mr. Lawrence has his
hand raised again, but we do acknowledge
your question and we will ask for that
from all our elected officials. Thank
you. So, um, who else do we have who's
going to speak? Oh, Spencer from,
um, Council Member Rivera's office. It's
here in person.
Everyone, good evening. Uh, I'm going to
keep it super brief. Just want to
highlight one upcoming event that our
office has in our report. We have a nice
little flyer here, too. Uh, it's on
Saturday, June 21st. It's at 55th Avenue
B, which is actually in the lot behind
that building. So, if you have any
confusion planning the event, go to
Fourth Street and it's in the lot behind
55 Avenue B. It's a family day and job
fair. We have a ton of organizations
from the city coming to give out
resources, identify job opportunities
for members of the community. We'll have
music, giveaways, food, etc. It should
be a very fun event. It's from 1 p.m. to
4 p.m. Saturday, June 21st. Again, uh
and happy to take any questions.
Great. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. So,
now we're now moving on to the public
session. I'd like to let you know that
um 78 people have signed up to speak in
this session. If everyone speaks for 3
minutes, we will be here for 4 hours. I
suggest that we try and amalgamate some
of your concerns and that if at all
possible, if you see that the person in
front of you mentions something that you
agree with, you simply say you agree and
we can move forward. We're going to do
this based there are two fairly um uh
robust issues that we're going to deal
with this evening. The first one is
going to be the Grammarcy Park Hotel and
we will have those people go first. But
um really we we would we need to vacate
this room at a certain time. So we'd
like you to respect all of the speakers
and to make this as brief as possible.
Okay. Uh there's actually one speaker
tonight that is not speaking on either
of the items that you all are here for.
So we will let them go first and then
move on to Driver Hotel.
They're the odd man out. Um,
okay.
Robert Scott, you are here to speak. Are
you here?
All right. You are here to speak about
uh the casino development. Uh, you have
three minutes. You may begin now.
Mr. Scott, your time is ticking.
You're muted. You're muted. Yes. Please
unmute yourself.
We may have to.
Yeah. See you your position.
You don't want to go at the end. Believe
me.
Okay.
Um and just one thing, once we call you
to speak, the timer will start.
Unfortunately, don't unmute yourself.
you lose your three minutes. It's all
counted as part of your three minutes.
So, let's keep let's move on.
Great.
Hello. Okay.
All right. Please go ahead. All right.
Thank you.
You have two minutes.
I understand. Several of our neighbors
have submitted a statement uh regarding
the location of a casino next to the
United Nations, a symbol for world peace
and world communication,
not
gambling and all that is implied with
it. There are other locations proposed
for gambling. two of them already
approved.
So that they ought to be given priority
and we urge that this location is simply
not suited for the traffic, the
automobile and other vehicular traffic
that would be involved. So there are
practical pragmatic reasons this is not
a good location
and there are symbolic reasons for our
American democracy,
a host to the United Nations, the
nations of the world to not be
symbolized by a casino. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay. Thank you.
We actually have a resolution in place
against having the casino located in
this particular location. All right,
we're moving on to the uh Gary Park
Hotel. Okay. All right. The first of the
on the list, Arlene Harrison,
are you here, Arlene,
or are you online?
Yes, Arlene is online. Arlene, your time
is ticking. Please proceed. And I'm
president of the Grammy Park Block
Association. The major focus of our work
for the past 35 years has been working
with over 40 neighborhood buildings in
addressing their quality of life
concerns. Therefore, we were most
grateful to the leadership of a newly
formed group of neighbors for reaching
out to us with concerns involving the
redevelopment of the Grammy Park Hotel.
We met and are fully supportive of their
commitment to working constructively
with the developer to address and
resolve their concerns. I believe we are
all excited about the reopening of our
beloved iconic hotel, which sadly has
been shuttered for many years now, and
we all want it to succeed. That being
said, there are three elements in the
current proposal that we all believe
need to be addressed and resolved in a
way that works for those who live here.
One, sidewalk cafe. Two, basement speak
easy. Three, rooftop bar. Sidewalk cafe.
There is concern about the pro proposed
size and hours of the sidewalk cafe. We
understand any cafe will require a
separate permit and public hearing and
we plan to raise concerns and work with
our neighbors to address them to address
them when the time comes. Basement speak
easy. A 4 a.m. liquor license and
removable furniture understandably raise
concerns about potential night lifestyle
use. Current plans are now open-ended
and we do not and do not preclude the
use that could negatively impact on our
neighbors. We strongly urge the
developer to include stipulations in the
liquor license that define a use
consistent with a quiet luxury hotel in
a residential neighborhood. Rooftop bar.
The noise from the rooftop bar has for
many years been a source of serious
disruption to our neighbors and
especially for our neighbors directly
across the street. Past op operators
blasted music late into the night
harming residents quality of life in
their own homes. We recommend a clear
stipulation in the liquor license that
the rooftop rollover should be closed by
1000 p.m. nightly. In conclusion, uh
these concerns go to the core of what it
means to live in this community. For
decades, families have built their lives
here with the expectation that the
peaceful residential character of
Grammar Park will be protected. The
success of this project depends on
whether our neighbors can continue to
enjoy the quiet, safe community that we
all have fought hard for to preserve. We
stand firmly with our neighbors and
believe these concerns must be fully
addressed as essential conditions moving
forward. Thank you.
Thank you for your comments.
Next on the list is Tyler Morse.
Tyler, are you here? Please come up.
Next on the list after that will be
Vincent Perry and Valerie Valerie
Foster. So get ready. Hi everybody.
Thank you for coming out tonight. My
name is Tyler Morse. Uh I'm the
developer of the Grand Park Hotel. Uh we
are thrilled to be bringing back an
iconic building uh a Bing and Bing uh
majestic building as a five-star hotel.
Uh this is not going to be a nightclub.
That is not our intention. Uh our
intention is that our guests can sleep
well at night and that you sleep well at
night. because that makes me sleep well
at night.
That is the purpose of why we are here.
Uh we are um we have gone out of our way
over the past year and a half to work
with the Grammy Park Block Association.
We meet with them weekly on site about
all kinds of different issues,
construction, uh threat, waste, and we
think we've kept a very clean community
uh at our own cost. We put in an urban
umbrella to make uh the sidewalk shed a
lot better. Right? We are very
interested in this community and we want
to be a part of this community for a
long time. Uh we love the community. We
are not here to create any problems. Uh
we have had many discussions as CD6
asked us to uh about a month ago uh with
the neighborhood association
uh with various neighbors. Uh we heard
your concerns. We listened to everything
you had to say. Uh we've made a lot of
concessions.
Uh this may not be known to everybody,
but we're happy to close uh the rollup
cover at 11 p.m. uh on the top level of
the building. Uh one of the concerns was
about setting up a community group uh so
communication can transpire. We're happy
to do that. Uh we hired an acoustician
uh at our expense who is the pre-minent
acoustician in New York City. Uh we are
going to follow all of the
recommendations of the acoustical report
uh on the sidewalk. Uh we still have to
get a department of transportation
permit uh for uh to occupy the sidewalk.
So uh we want to table that. There's
going to be another bite at this apple
uh on the sidewalk. Um, and we have uh a
dozen liquor licenses in New York City
and across the country and we've never
had issues. So, we think that our track
record speaks for ourself. This is a
five-star hotel. Uh, I'm not aware of a
Four Seasons Hotel or Crosby Street
Hotel or a Sur Hotel that's ever had
alcohol uh violation issues. We are not
creating a nightclub here. uh we are
bringing back an iconic asset uh that is
important to the community and we stand
by the uh licensing committee and their
unanimous approval of our license
application about a month ago. Let me
just repeat unanimous approval from
community board 6 uh liquor licensing
committee. Uh we worked very hard at
that. We worked with the community. Uh
we talked about every issue with that
board. uh they're all here and we were
very pleased to get that unanimous
approval. So, thank you all for being
here and thank you all for listening and
we look forward to being part of the
community.
Thank you. All right, next on the list
is Vincent Perry. Vincent Perry.
Hi, my name is Vince Perry. I'm on the
board of 60 Gishy Park North, otherwise
known as 21st Street. Uh, I was going to
talk about the uh the cafe outside, but
I feel it totally necessary to address
some of the comments from uh our last
speaker. Um, my knowledge and we we
belong to the uh neighborhood working
group which represents nine buildings in
the community. All right. And that's
over a thousand residents. None of us
were informed at all either formally or
by email about the development of the
hotel. Not one communication with, as
far as I know, R9 buildings. Okay. As
far as the uh licensing committee of the
uh uh the C6, the truth is that they
voted down the application to go back
and insist on the hotel to to enter into
discussions with us. 20-19 was the vote.
You can look at the meeting minutes of
those meetings. Um, as far as uh this
neighborly
uh claim uh that the hotel is going to
be a good neighbor, um they haven't they
haven't sought any input from our
community. Um they are the neighborhood
is very pro hotel. We want the hotel.
The hotel is not pro neighborhood.
Neighbors should talk to the people
surrounding them. All right. We call for
a resolution of objection so that we can
have the time, the due diligence that we
have been denied to enter into
discussions with a mutually satisfying
resolution. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Valerie Bostory,
please come up. After that, it will be
Sophie Prader and David Gain.
All right, Miss uh Bostory, you have
three minutes. Yeah, you do. My name is
Valerie Bostory. I'm on the board for
Lexington, next door to the hotel. Um,
first I'd like to thank the community
board for listening to our concerns. Um,
and I want to ask you to pause and get
liquor license for the NCR or any other
further development.
I come to you in three capacities.
as a 30year 30 neighbor of the hotel or
resident living there for 30 years as a
board member for 16 years on the board.
So I have a deep institutional knowledge
of how the Grand Park Hotel has
interacted with their neighbors and I
have to agree with you sir that it has
not been friendly.
Um, I also want to talk about um
our beautiful historic landmark
neighborhood. Um, has very narrow
streets and sidewalks with no through
streets.
The traffic whether by foot or vehicle
is very difficult.
such a largecale commercial venue
including Southern Nightclub, Rooftop
Club until 400 a.m. and um outdoor
seating is not a safe environment for
our neighborhood.
My apartment faces the interior
courtyard of the hotel.
I've experienced firsthand the
vibration, the noise, and the
nonresponsiveness
of the hotel management to turn the
music down.
They have soundproofed
hotel rooms, but they have not
soundproofed residents adjoining their
bu their hotel.
I also wanted to point out about the
commercial again, the outdoor seating.
We're on 23rd Street. The Department of
Traffic has a sign up, no through
traffic, because on many, many, many
occasions, vehicles get jack knifed
right on that corner.
So, it is not a safe way to put tables
and the noise level has not been
addressed.
Uh, I want to just maybe thank you again
and ask you to please reconsider
approving moving forward with any more
development of the Grand Mercy Bar Hotel
because they have not been communicating
with their neighbors. Uh, the Grand Ry
Park Association
Harrison is not the only member. We are
adjacent to that hotel and we have not
been consulted in anything. And that
seems like it's the same for 60 gram
seed, seven less. Thank you. Thank you
very much. We are commends.
Next on the list, Sophie Prader Prader,
are we here? Uh David Gaines,
uh Robin Sutenberg, you going? Uh is
Sophie here? If she is not here, we'll
move on. Okay, let's move on. David
Gaines,
would you please
wait for the microphone?
Robin Suttonberg, are you here? Because
you're next. Okay.
My name is Dains. I'm a resident of 39y
Park North
in the entrance and some being covered.
I'll reserve my comments about the
rooftop bar and about the sidewalk cafe.
Um, I have been a resident in my
building for 29 years. And I will say
that 2 years after we moved in at an
annual meeting of our building, I stood
and asked our president anything could
be done about the noise on Gary Park
North and he said, "You'll get used to
it. I'm still waiting." So, there we
are. And now we have this project. I
know that our developer says that uh
this is not going to be a nightclub. But
with 400 to 500 seats of entertainment
and 200 rooms, the ratio of hospitality
um entertainment to rooms is enormous
and it can't be viewed any other way. So
I'll talk about traffic for just a
moment. Traffic at the intersection is
chronically heavy and often gridlocked.
What is the plan for hundreds of
vehicles needing access for drop off and
standing zones all day and night? I'm
not hearing anything about that.
Residents already live with backups for
blocks, blaring horns, cars routinely
ignoring red lights at the corner and
emergency vehicles that cannot pass and
sound their sirens into the night.
With this project in mind, a whole block
of city bikes was installed directly
across the street where a drop off zone
might have been created. What
forethought is being applied for an
intersection that is already on
overload? Please protect our quality of
life and scale the project back. Thank
you. Thank you for your remarks.
Robin Robin Suttonberg, you are next.
Three minutes beginning now. I'm Rob
Sber and I resigned at 39 Grand Park
North for approximately 40 years. I am
pleased that the Grand Park Hotel which
has been an isore since it closing 5
years ago is reopening. However, my
neighbors and I have concerns regarding
the proposed public spaces. We are a
quiet residential block and three floors
of bars, a private club and especially
outdoor seating are more than amenities
to the hotel guests. These drinking
establishments would significantly
disturb the residential character of our
neighborhood and present traffic safety
and quality of life issues. My neighbors
and I were unaware of the business
affairs meeting which considered the
hotel's liquor license. Had we known, we
would have appeared to express our
concerns and seek answers to the many
questions we have which apparently were
not addressed or considered at the
initial business affairs meeting. For
example, there are three entities
applying for one Lego license for the
premises. What are the relationships and
responsibilities among these entities?
Are they all operating all areas of the
requested one license or are they each
operating individual areas? Who do we
complain to if there are problems? The
plan shows sidewalk seating on the hotel
perimeters on Lexington Avenue and Grid
Park North designated as of right as
within the lot lines of the hotel. Where
are the lot lines? They were not
included on the plans.
Uh what is the distance between the
sidewalk seating and the curb? Will
there be unobstructed
pedestrian mobility?
How did the license
had license holders intend to mitigate
their sidewalk cafe? Odors from food
served outside brought in another
testing station and where will the
patrons stand while waiting for a table
on the street? There's one lane of
southbound traffic in front of the hotel
on Lexington Avenue and one lane of
traffic was found on Brady Cross Port.
How does the hotel intend to handle
cars, Ubers, and cabs, obstructing
emergency vehicles and traffic on both
streets while dropping off and picking
up patrons? The plans indicate that
threeth forest can accommodate over a
thousand patrons, not including hotel
guests. The largest application indicate
no plans for security.
Thank you.
Thank you for your remarks.
Next on the list is Nancy Binham. Nancy
Binham, I believe you're online. You
have three minutes. You may begin now.
Thank you. Can you hear me? Yes. Okay.
Uh, yes. My name is Nancy Binham. I have
been a resident at 60 Grammarcy Park
North for 27 years. Thank you so much
for allowing me to speak tonight. Um,
first I'd like to say that as close
neighbors to the hotel, we're excited to
see it come back to life, but there are
a few elements of their plan that are of
particular concern to me, my family, and
my neighbors. Uh, first, I'd like to
address the hotel's request for sidewalk
dining and drinking on Lexington Avenue
in Gramarcy Park North. I venture to say
that all of us who have chosen to live
on these quiet streets have done so in
part because they form a peaceful oasis
in the heart of one of the busiest
neighborhoods in Manhattan. Sidewalk
seating will fundamentally diminish the
quality of life for those of us living
here. The noise, the obstruction of the
sidewalk by tables, chairs, waiters, and
hundreds of customers. The general
commotion and the trash that come with
sidewalk seating would without a doubt
have a material adverse impact on those
of us living on these blocks. It will
also surely exacerbate an already
serious rat problem. Uh to my knowledge,
sidewalk seating has never been allowed
at this location in the hotel's 100 plus
year history. And the sidewalks are
heavily used by families with strollers,
senior citizens, dog walkers, and people
with disabilities. There are two large
sidewalk grates on Grammarly Park North.
one placed closer to the building and
the other closer to the street. That
would force pedestrians either to walk
on the grates, which if you're a dog
walker, you know that's difficult, or be
channeled onto narrow strips between the
tables or along the edge. I strongly
oppose sidewalk seating of any kind,
shed or no shed, and of any capacity.
Secondly, I understand that the current
plan includes a rooftop club with live
music, DJs, and service until 4 a.m.,
which I just don't think is appropriate
for a residential area. I served on my
building's board for 18 years, and I
know from my time as a board member that
the noise from the rooftop bar in the
hotel's earlier incarnation represented
a serious hardship to neighbors in my
building whose apartments are adjacent
to the hotel. I don't have an issue with
the rooftop bar, per se, but I believe
that it should operate in compliance
with the city's noise code. which has a
10 p.m. curfew for outdoor spaces, not
11 p.m. as was stated by the owner. In
conclusion, I ask that you consider a
resolution of objection to this
application tonight, taking into account
the concerns of myself and the Grammar
neighborhood.
Thank you for your remarks. Next on the
list, Orin. And I just might note we
have 30 additional people who wish to
speak on this topic.
If anyone would like to consolidate
their comments, we would greatly
appreciate that.
It's it is quite repetitive and um I
think you have to assume that people
here do understand. We might take a show
of hands. Who here is is against the the
application as it stands?
Who is against the application as it
stands in our resolution?
So, let's count.
Yes.
I'd like to see a show of hands of those
people here who are against our
resolution as it currently stands.
This is just the public, please. Our
members will vote later. So, could we
please count?
I hope someone else is counting.
We'll do online next.
12 online. 12 online with hands raised.
Yeah. Yeah. 12. All right.
And in the moon
27.
So um actually one of you didn't sign up
to speak because we have 38 more um
coming up. But I hope you understand
that this is going to be an extremely
lengthy meeting if we have to go through
everyone's comments and they do tend to
be repetitive. Is there someone who'd
like to make a sort of general comment
for the I have a question. Certainly ask
for a show of hands of those in favor.
I'm sorry. Yes, please. Let's have a
show of hands for those in favor.
Five. Five. Okay. What about online and
online? Uh
community six. Yeah, exactly.
Thank you. One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight. Eight.
Okay.
So, um, we can keep continuing with with
people's comments, but, um, I think it
might in in the interest of time, it
would be would be really helpful if we
can move on. We are not voting on this
until later in the evening.
It will come up in our agenda. I think
everyone saw the agenda.
You have a separate point, not repeating
whatever. If you're not repeating the
previous points, I think that would be
welcomed. Why don't we ask everyone just
try to stick to one minute and not
repeat?
Still 38 minutes.
I think it would be really helpful if we
could consolidate, but we are a
democracy. We'll certainly try and move
forward. But um I think we get I think
everyone here sort of understands the
positions. If you feel you have
something that's to add to the
conversation, please raise your hand and
we'll let you speak.
Can we ask someone who's in favor to
speak? We've only heard Well, I think
the people in favor have signed up. Oh,
they have.
Did you out online as well yet? Yes, we
have.
We have f We have a total of um 13 in
favor and 38 against. Um so, all right.
If you'd like to make We have three
additional people who want to speak,
please come forward.
I'll be very brief and I want to make a
point that has not been addressed yet
which is the question of the extent to
what was the burn operator being
tarnished by a sensor
operator and I think it's very important
to be clear that's not what's going on
here. I'm perfectly willing to believe
the good faith of the ground operator,
but the the history says that the
project is inherently problematic and
especially the roof deck. It you know
the code requires uh no unreasonable
noise after 10 p.m. There's an offering.
I believe that a chalice playing the
cello suite solo at 10:05 p.m. with the
roof open would constitute unreasonable
noise. Like it would wake you up.
There's no death. It's very very very
hard to not generate unreasonable noise
from that location with a cover open. So
it's not about the prior operators but
the inherent risk and because of the
inherent risk this process is needed
which are enforcable credible mechanisms
to address the concerns of the
community.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Macy, I also live in one
life. I just wanted to make the point
that let's assume for the sake of
argument MCR complied with all the
posting notice requirements. We know the
paperwork was filled out. We found that
the committee did its due diligence,
etc. Those things may all be true. But
be that as it may, for a variety of
reasons that aren't worth relitigating
today, the community was underinformed
and underengaged. So the community voice
was not heard. And while it's
understandable that the committee the
committee's frustrated at taking a step
backward and no one wants to waste the
board and committee's time, it would be
wrong nonetheless and create like bad
incentives for the future if the
proposal's approved simply by virtue of
the developer skill in staying under the
radar in the early stages of
development.
Just because we didn't hear about it and
now we're going to be, you know, it's
going to be swept, our concerns are
going to be swept aside. I don't think
that makes sense.
I believe I was called as well.
Okay.
I've never spoken for one minute.
Let's try it.
My wife my biggest concerns are with the
noise as well.
your name and how how can a nightclub be
allowed in this residential
neighborhood? I would not have to
remember studio 54
entrance were around the lot at all
hours even when the club was virtually
empty to give the illusion of massive
demand. The noise from these lines was
deafening. the best solution is not to
allow a nightclub and we just I thought
heard a little individually there will
not be a nightclub or it is not a night
I'm not sure what that meant but if it's
true that's terrific but if it's
approved for some god offer reason there
must be enforcable restrictions i.e. No
one allowed outside except for coming
and going. No interest line. No smoking
area. The decible levels must be kept
monitored and enforced to be within
allowable limits. During the hotel's
previous ownership, when the city
prohibited smoking in bars, its patrons
would come out on the sidewalk to smoke
and under the influence of it of alcohol
would
bow and laugh and well into the early
morning inhibiting all of us from
sleeping. Thank you. What building are
you from? building where you
the name and where you lived. So I've
been
48 years
45 I'm sorry moved in 198 Oh my god.
I believe I was called from online
or
he was the one that was next. Okay,
please go ahead. Hi, my name is I'll
make it Yeah, I'll make it fast. My name
is Orio. I live in Fort Lexington, the
building adjacent to the hotel. My
apartment faces the interior courtyard
as well. Everyone's discussing the noise
issue which is absolutely correct. I
just want to be a bit more specific and
that it is the base that travels up from
both the basement and the rooftop which
is on a different test different level
of noise. It actually as as another
neighbors claimed causes vibrations. All
right. If you look at the actual study
that was conducted by your quote unquote
best in New York City, you will see in
that report and the study, he had the
same issues with the bass levels called
with the speakers that are used. So when
we say noise, it's noise and vibrations
and bass. And I'll also second the the
comp the traffic, both cab and Uber
traffic, the loiterers that are smoking
outside late at night. Again, we're all
in favor of the hotel reopening. love
it, but it needs to be done respectfully
and at hours that are respectful to this
residential area. And I'll end with I
agree that frankly it's an insult to
give us such little notice to do our
diligence and make our our concerns
communicated. Thank you so much.
Do we have anyone else who'd like to
speak?
Okay.
at 16.
Um, we shared the sidewalk with the
hotel. Um, I understood from Tyler
Morris uh that there is not going to be
a dance club that serves 240 people.
That is different than what we've been
told. Is that in fact the statement of
fact that there is not going to be a
dance club in the south that serves 240
people?
Can I get an answer to that or this is
not a trial but I'm I'm being impuged.
My integrity is being uh eviscerated
here not a which more satisfying. You
don't have to answer my question but
goes to my point. My point is is that I
live on the second floor of Grammarly
Park, uh, 60 Grammy Park North. There
are going to be people smoking
cigarettes. They're going to be What is
your demographic for a dance club that
serves 240 people liquor? It's probably
21 to 26 years old. We're going to have
people slamming six shots and then
smoking cigarettes under my window. And
I do not want that. I will not be able
to sleep. The New York City noise law is
1000 p.m. to 700 a.m. We want our
neighborhood quiet from 1000 p.m. to 7
a.m. We don't want bumper to bumper a
full bird is lit on taxi cab blow
blowing their horns under our windows at
4 a.m. when you dump 240 people out of
the bar.
And I think that's
Do we have anyone else who would like to
speak? We'd like to move on if we
Hey,
I'm here because what's being proposed
for the R Park Hotel isn't just a liquor
license. It's It isn't speak easy. It's
not a night log. It's not a lounge. It's
a mess. Mr. Morris's remarks and
equivocations aside, NCR's T uh TW hotel
doesn't face these issues. It's in the
middle of the airport, but their
highlight hotel is in the rental
neighborhood. The following is based on
public documents I'm happy to provide
because the record still matters. The
landmarks preservation commission has in
the past found that NCR has installed RS
in areas without permit. He was found by
community board 4 to be out of
compliance with noise laws, possibly
state liquor laws and involved in
year-long dispute over the word over the
meaning of the word music. This isn't
about me or you or they or them. It's
about how we organize our lives
together, compromise commitment and
community standards that work. We we
need earlier music cut off times, a real
plan for how people will move in and out
of venture space, drastically reduce
sidewalk aphase, earn an impartial
acoustic study, and a scale of use that
fits the block in our human and canine
community.
We'll have three people online who have
requested to speak.
Edith Charlton, you're up next. Up next.
Go ahead.
My name is Edith Charlton and I have
lived at 60 Gasy Park for 65 years. My
building is part of the neighborhood
working group. I strongly object to
granting liquor licenses to MCR for use
in their proposals for a roof garden
open until 4 a.m. a speak easy for 240
occupancy,
outdoor dining and other entertainment
venues that MCR has proposed in the
past. Except for the roof garden, these
are all new venues requiring new liquor
licenses.
We are already surrounded by bars and
restaurants on Third Avenue and Park
Avenue South. I have also heard of a
wine bar opening at 38 Gazy Park,
causing someone at your last liquor
licensing meeting to call 21st Street a
bar corridor. if the hotel's massive
outdoor dining is permitted.
MCR has not involved our community at
all regarding their plans for the hotel.
No contact. That is difficult to
understand since there is to be outdoor
seating for 93
hours from 7:00 a.m. to 4 a.m. I believe
this new hotel will become more of an
entertainment center than a residential
hotel if liquor licenses are granted for
the entire hotel, its interior and
exterior, meaning 21st Street and
Lexington Avenue.
According to Samuel Ruggle's deed, Gary
Park is the name of both a private park
and surrounding neighborhood.
Has this deed been studied by the board?
Has the hotel's impact on our community
been discussed regarding deliveries,
noise, increased food traded
vehicle traffic at all hours, which our
streets and sidewalks were not intended
to handle. Our residential neighborhood
will be greatly affected if all these
liquor licenses requested are granted.
In July of 1916,
this neighborhood was proclaimed a
residential district. Let's work to keep
it that way, and I hope you will object
to their applications. Thank you.
Next on the list is Susan Lindenhower.
Uh, Miss Lindenhower, you have three
minutes to speak. You may begin now.
You can't speak if you're muted.
Let's move on to Stephen Reed, please.
Thank you. Okay. Thank you.
Um
just wait one moment.
Your time is started. Please uh
please proceed.
I am Susan Lindau. I am Susan
Lindenhower. I am uh a
resident of 45 Grammarcy Park North for
more than 50 years. Uh
I really love the community in which I
live. Uh and I really hope that the
hotel which was at one point a vibrant
part of the community can become one uh
in the future. I look forward to being
able to dine as I have in the past in
the hotel. And I in fact used uh the
rooms in the hotel to put up guests for
my family for a number of occasions. I
really hope that the hotel recognizes
that it is located in a beautiful area
that has some
in inhibiting factors. namely Lexington
Avenue ends at Grammarly Park and
vehicles that travel on
Lexington Avenue have to make a turn at
a very
narrow righthand turn uh onto 21st
Street. 21st Street at the same time is
a through street used by traffic,
general traffic, by trucks and by also
the police precinct which is located one
block away on 21st Street. This creates
enormous traffic problems today. And if
we had a outdoor cafe
existing with those conditions, it would
make it even far worse for the residents
of the community uh and for the guests
at the hotel. the traffic would be
impeded by significant number of people
dro being dropped off uh in cars, Uvers
or whatever. Uh I really think that the
hotel
would will be a wonderful addition to
the community but I think the
notion of a large That's time. Thank
you. Thank you for your comments. Um, I
think we have one more person. It looks
like their hand has gone down. Their
hand's gone down. Um,
do we have anyone here who'd like to
speak in favor of the hotel? We've heard
uh sir, go ahead.
Three minutes starting now. I'm Alan
Firestein. I'm the acoustic consultant
for the hotel. I wrote the report that
you guys have gotten and I've heard the
comments that you made in the past and
also tonight
and I agree with your concerns. I do a
lot of work for people who are disturbed
by noise by bars, nightclubs,
restaurants. I've been doing this for 49
years.
The recommendations I made address bass,
mid-range sound, and treble sounds. In
my report, I have recommendations for
how loud the sound systems can be and
how they have to be locked and limited
both in the cellar, which is below
grade, and there's no direct entrance to
the street
on the first floor, the second floor,
and on the rooftop. I've addressed the
roller cover and I made recommendations
for how loud the sound can be in all
those locations with a lock limiter. I
even put in in my report a data sheet
for the limiter that I usually recommend
which is very successfully implemented
and I've also put in recommendations for
how to lower the base so the base is
also locked at a low level.
Too often,
nightclubs, bars, especially rooftops
play music uncontrolled, unlimited. They
don't have any clue as to how loud the
sound should be. They disturb the
neighbors. It causes labor license
problems, even violations.
Unfortunately, PE inspectors, as many of
you know, are not really up to snuff in
terms of dealing with these problems. So
it really had to be started to work be
worked on right from the beginning. I
worked for a number of years with Rich
and Dyra DCA in an attempt to make this
a requirement for all bars and
nightclubs that they have to do a sound
study and adhere to recommendations. So
typically boards do is they accept
stipulations saying this will happen,
this will be enforced and will be
monitored. So that's what I'm
recommending. I put it in my report and
I'll be happy to answer any questions
from anyone either before or after the
meeting or during. Thank you.
Um I suggest that if you have questions
for the acquisition that would be done
outside of our meeting, please. Thank
you. You have a comment that impacts his
report. Can we make that quickly? I do
not think his report takes into account
uh the full capacity of the over 300
people that were going to be in the uh
in the establishment. So we would ask
that you look at that and that you
disregard the report because it's not it
may not be accurate. Although we weren't
the same capacities as it was.
Yeah. Let's please we're not here to
just we're not here to um argue facts.
Please, please, if you have questions
for the acquisition, I think you can do
it um later. Um we we've heard the
information. I'm not sure there's much
else we can do to to help that. So, is
anyone else want to make a comment who
has not already made a comment?
I'll be David Johnson. I live on
Lexington.
Other
people and others have adequately
discussed the speak easy concerns the
sidewalk dining concerns the rooftops
simply had on the traffic. Let's not
forget the 13
is a block away. It travels on that 21st
street. So that's we got to be completed
traffic studies. I just wonder given the
fact the hotel's not going to open for
more than a year, why why not a pause on
the liquor license till everything
been been fully. Thank you.
All right. Can we move on, please? Uh
sir, if you have brief comments. I do.
Well, you need the microphone, please,
or people won't be able to hear you.
that when we were voting or when we were
recording our vote here, there were a
number of hands raised back with the MCR
group and I think it's worth uh worth
saying and this is only a room with so
many people in it and the proportion was
drastically affected by people who who
were raising their hands in favor of a
hotel when I think a significant portion
of the people in the room were hotel
employees I would assume. Um, and sir, I
think we're taking that count more in
terms of trying to limit the number of
speakers. It's not an issue of like
who's for against. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. We will move on to our next
issue.
I'm sorry.
Do we have someone else who wanted to
speak?
Hi, my name is Rebecca. I'm a director
at MCR. I'm in charge of design and
programming for our independent hotel.
Um I'm also married to Mars. We've been
married for almost 20 years and we both
live in CB6, but we do live on 12
street. So we're neighbors a little bit
to this side. Um we have two young
daughters and we live in a city um
neighborhood as well. So we very much
understand your concerns and it is my
deepest hope that a year or two from now
we are all together in the Birmy Park
Hotel has been awesome addition to your
incredibly strenful neighborhood uh that
we've loved to learn more about and
being a part of over the last two years
we worked extensively with the GCY Park
Association which we be an organ
organization of 2,000 people that lived
in the neighborhood. We've attended
Christmas tree lightings in the middle
of Fantasy Park. Our children led the
Halloween parade all around the
perimeter of the park for the last two
years running. I really hope they do it
again next year. So, I just want to let
you know that the kind of establishment
we want to run is one that is
familyfriendly. We're a family business.
We are going to be there all the time.
Um, I'm sure you can also understand as
a fivestar hotel, the last thing we want
is people standing outside all the hours
of the day and making noise. that would
not make for a great hotel. That's for
sure. And we want it to be a great
hotel. Uh the property has been was
purpose built as a hotel in 1925 and
it's been a hotel all those years since.
Is our intention to return it to
something that is worthy of your
neighborhood. That is the spirit and
soul of of the 1925 era in which it was
built um and is worthy again of the
architecture and the soul of your
neighborhood.
you know,
show you the kind of
the Gravity Park Live Association does
not Excuse me, sir. Please, please.
Uh, we have two other people who have
raised their hands. If they have
additional comments, please go ahead.
Brian Manning,
please go ahead. Hi, my name is Brian
Manning. I'm a resident of one Lexington
Avenue for almost 10 years and I've
consolidated my statement just to the
two core issues that I have. The current
proposal allowing for liquor to be
served in multiple locations including
the outdoor dining area could really
become a noisy waiting spot for people
waiting to get into the clubs and
multiple venues andor leaving the speak
easys main floor bars and everything
else. Between this and the increased
capacity across venues, it'll further
exacerbate an already congested
intersection, especially problematic for
emergency vehicles. The other is the
sound systems. There has to be a
solution for lowering and sealing the
roof or whatever needs to be done to
comply with the New York City sound
guidelines, which I believe are 10:00
p.m., not 11:00 a.m. Um, as I mentioned
before, uh, the hotel is very personal
to me. My wife and I were married there.
where he hosted colleagues and friends
and everything there. And I'm an
entrepreneur. I fully support a
revitalized GPH in in the neighborhood,
but it has to fit the e ethos of the
neighborhood. So, I'm hoping CB6 will
take this into account and and form get
it formally addressed by the developer
before approving this application. Thank
you.
All right, our last speaker is Stephen
Reed.
Uh, hi. Can everyone hear me? Yes. Yeah.
Uh so I echo everything that uh everyone
has said about the concerns about the
neighborhood. I've lived in the
neighborhood since the mid 90s uh uh for
since 2001. I've lived at 60 Park North.
The the neighborhood is first and
foremost a quiet one. Uh my building
happens to share a back courtyard with
the hotel. And while everyone I know is
generally welcoming and even excited
about the hotel, uh we're all very upset
to hear about the plans to potentially
put in a base thumping club literally
right at our own back door with further
plans to clog the sidewalks with outdoor
seating and the rooftop bar and music.
Right. So all that is good. I I I echo
it. I' I've tried to con condense this
down. I living here there were times
where in the prior incarnation of the
hotel there were parties being held
there or events or or uh ceremonies and
when the bands or DJs were playing you
could it it would it wasn't that it was
super loud outside. It was as somebody
had pointed out the bass thumping uh
shaking of the building was the thing
that was uh most awful. great to hear
that the hotel is very uh concerned
about our our concerns and will not do
that. But if something happens and they
do and there's a change of ownership and
suddenly um there is uh you know there
are people uh that come late night and
we want to keep the bars the bars open
and play loud music. There is no
recourse then for anybody else in the
neighborhood to be able to do anything
about it and that's the thing that
concerns me the most. Uh, so I would
strongly recommend that we disallow the
current proposal from the hotel until
there's more time to discuss what the
controls could be around it. Thank you.
Okay, we actually do have one final
person who would like to speak. Um,
Mr. Bernstein, Mr. Bernstein, who has
Thank you everyone. My name's Donald
Bernstein. I'm Tyler's attorney in
commission with this application.
I I I've been doing this a long time. I
hear these sorts of issues all of the
time and as Alan Firestein said, some of
the neighbors have some reasonable
concerns about noise and I understand
that but we can deal with it. What I
don't appreciate, however, is the
malignment of Tyler Morris. I think that
is unfair that should not be permitted
in this meeting. Tyler for a year and a
half has spoken to the ground park
association on a regular. You know, I
didn't last at your comments, so you
have to give me my time to speak and not
be rude.
Please, please continue. He has spoken
to this block association, had every
reason to believe that this block
association represented the community
and had regular ongoing discussions with
them, and also spoke to some people in
other buildings. He presumably didn't
speak to the people in this room, but
did find out about the fact that they
didn't work with the bar association
until we were here a month ago. And as
you asked us to do last month, over the
past few weeks, we had met with
residents and we've spoken to them about
these issues. So all of that stuff
doesn't matter. Here we are today. We
know what their issues are and we've
addressed them. Some of the general
issues, let me speak. Some of the
general issues
um are the fact that this is a hotel.
This is not like this was a vacant lot.
This is not like there was a nail salon
here and we're erecting this 20story
hotel. This has been a licensed hotel
since 1933. For 90 years, this has been
a licensed hotel. The building's not
changing. It's the same building. Now,
with respect to the issues that are of
concern, we can address them. The
rooftop, unlike Steven Greenberg, a club
operator, Ian Shraderger, a club
operator, AB Rosen, a real estate, Tyler
has 150 hotels throughout the country.
Do you know how many nightclubs he has?
Zero. Not a single one. Now, as Alan
Ferstein told you, and we commissioned
him, we had to pay him a lot of money to
do the studies. Why did we do the study?
Because we want to make sure noise is
not going to be a problem. That's why
it's not for show. It's for real. He's
the most honored and respected
acoustician in the city. Still, people
malign him and laugh at him, but he is.
And as he said, he often represents
residents if he believes and knows that
they are right. Unlike all of the
private operators, we will have a roller
cover that will close by 11 p.m. And
there is no law that says that you can't
have people outside after 10. I don't
know where people are getting it from.
That is not correct. We would close it
at 11 p.m. So that there will be no
outdoor space and rooftop. Excuse me,
sir. Stop.
Could you please be quiet and let him
speak? I don't think I interrupted any
of the people that spoke before, so I
deserve a little respect there. There
will be no outdoor space in the rooftop
after 11 p.m. the outdoor seating on the
uh outside on the ground floor level. We
are not applying for a sidewalk cafe. If
we decide we want to have one and next
year we'll come back. We'll go to DOT.
We'll deal with that. Then with respect
to the seller space, this is so great.
There are no windows. We have agreed
after the twist of the neighborhood that
there be no direct access onto the
street. We added a few seconds for the
interruptions, but yes, it is time.
Great. We hope that you support the
resolution of your committee. Thank you.
Thank you. We will move on to our next
issue.
We'd let we and please we're not having
questions. If you'd like to ask a
question, you can. He happened to speak
last. This lawyer guy just happened to
raise his hand as the very last Could
you please calm down? We asked who else
wanted to speak. There are no other
raised hands of people. Is there anyone
here who would like to speak who has not
spoken already?
Okay, then please go ahead.
I've been listening. You need the
microphone, please. Sorry.
Hi, my name is Patricia Star. I've been
listening to all of you. I'm I I live at
seven Lexington for 35 years. I live in
an apartment on Lex that faces the
hotel. I've also been on my board for 20
years. So, I think I've had a front row
seat to every iteration of this hotel. I
think I hear everybody but I think what
NCR is missing is the in tremendous
increase in capacity and living here
even in the old hotel with much less
capacity
um not they didn't have the 240 seat uh
speak easy that they're proposing no
sidewalk seating. So even without that
capacity there were double parked idling
cars honking horns to all hours. Very
diff difficulty for our residents to our
ultra residents who are handicapped with
walkers. We have a lot of young families
with strollers almost impossible to park
in front of our building and empty a car
and and fill up a car. And it was it
affected our life greatly. And I think
the big one of the big issues we'd like
to address is this tremendous increase
of capacity. We feel that it is not we
the traffic will be unacceptable.
So I just wanted to make that as an you
know an additional point.
We'd like to move on.
We do have one more person who has
raised their hand.
Do you really want to speak?
Holly Dando, you have three minutes
starting now. Sorry, I just had to
unmute. Can you hear me now? Yes. Okay,
great. My name's Holly Dando. I've lived
at 60 Garcy Park North for over 20
years. I moved here because it's a quiet
and safe place to call home. I'm deeply
concerned about the plans for the
redevelopment of the hotel. While my
concerns relate to noise, hour hours of
operation and beyond, I want to talk
about safety. I offer these comments as
someone with mobility challenges that
have required me to use a cane or a
walker since 2022. The out for Lexington
Avenue in Gary Park North is outsized 93
seats where there has been a single
sidewalk seat for 100 years. This will
eat up the sidewalk and make the streets
unpassable. I rely on both these streets
in my daily living. 93 seats will eat
up. Sorry, repeat. It will be a public
nuisance for people like me. Traffic
will seize to a halt with the coming and
going of this new venue. I believe it's
best to avoid sidewalk dining overall at
21st and less. It will turn this corner
into a street show of diners, servers,
and others. It will block police
vehicles from the 13th precinct from
timely response to emergencies. I ask
the community board to consider my clear
objection to the proposed plan. It's not
safe. Thank you. Thank you. We will now
move on to our next issue. Um, as you
can see, time is running out for this
meeting. We'd like to have the same We'd
like to have maybe a show of hands for
everyone here who's here for the 34th
Street busway. Who is in first? Let's go
with who is against the busway? We'll
just have a show of hands.
against.
Please keep your hands raised. Sorry. We
have one, two, three, four, five, six,
right? 6 7 8 9 10 11. And for those
against or those four, if you could
please raise your hands. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11. And
online, please. Like eight. Eight. 10.
10. So we have eight again.
Um Oh, he's gone.
Okay. Can you make up your mind? Yeah.
So, it would be really fantastic if we
could have several people from each side
represent what they'd like to say and
then we move forward. Um,
check your reports. Yeah.
Um,
would that be acceptable if we had say
three people from each side?
No.
I think it would be acceptable. Yeah.
All right.
We're going to go. We're going to go.
We'll start the list, but we cannot hear
everybody. I hope people understand
that. On order. Yes. If you as chair
determine that the comments are
repetitive or deliatory,
you can is that in Robert's room.
Excellent. Thank you. Please do so.
Okay.
And and you know, out of kindness, we
will ask our high school students first.
Um, okay. Let's go ahead. Please come
up. We don't know your name, but we'll
cross you off the list as you stay start
with your name and then you'll have
three minutes. Okay, but be brief. You
can
Hey, I'm August Boy. I'm a member of
Transportation Alternatives, a youth
activist committee.
Uh my name is Chris and I'm also a
member of the transportation
alternatives youth activist committee.
Uh so we had gone over I believe it's
the Murray Hill Neighborhood
Association's
uh website and saw some of their
complaints about the street bus and we
just wanted to go over a couple of those
points and address them. So um one
complaint was that fat that is saying
that fat is disappearing. Uh I believe
that what they're saying is that with
the 14th Street busway, people are
transitioning their mode of travel as a
result of this with you know best ways
for traffic. People are moving to other
transit.
Um we also heard a complaint about air
waste pollution. We believe that the
34th Street will help damage this
actually because
like I said
the transit
and some worry it'll displace traffic
but we've seen with the 14th street uh
bus way that this simply doesn't happen
and local street travel times barely
increase and critically on 14th street
buses bus speeds increase by as much as
24% and the DT is estimating a 15% speed
increase on uh 13th Street, which is a
significant improvement.
Uh and on a personal note of 14th
Street, I ride 14D to the school every
day from Union Square down to Avenue D
and Alston. And for the section where I
get to go on the bus way, bus speeds are
significantly faster. And uh we also
heard one complaint was that uh 34
Street is different because of the
tunnel access on the other side. Uh we
wanted to point to 181st Street which is
also located at busway where uh there's
the George Washington Bridge in New
Jersey and I believe the Washington
Bridge over uh the Bronx on either side
of it and uh despite those similar
connections to 34th Street. Uh it's
scale improved commutes for over 42,000
bus riders. uh or the 62 or 70% of
unfairly associated users who take the
bus. So a busy can still be successful
even when it has you know connections to
voter on each side.
Yeah. And as an East Harland resident,
for many people in my comm community,
accessing Midtown and other parts of the
city often relies on like efficient bus
connections. Um, particularly on nature
across town streets like 34th. Um, and
when these buses get stuck in traffic,
it directly impacts our ability to go to
work, school like, and extracurriculars,
adding to like time and preparation.
So, thank you. Thank you.
Okay,
thank you very much. So,
let's have someone who's against the bus
way. Please raise your hand. Who wants
to speak?
This gentleman's will let him go.
Oh, the one I said the one in the back.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead. Thank you for see. My name is
Brit Smith. I live at 114 East 36th
Street. Um, I would just like to say
that there's basically a lack of
conclusive data available uh on the
impact of this proposal. I ask that the
board and community board or elected
officials please pause on voting for
this project. I'm going to quote Rachel
Eisenberg from last week's Department of
Transfer from the Department of
Transportation on last week's June 2nd
CB6 transportation committee meeting
posted
YouTube um at 27 minutes and 15 seconds.
She said, quote, "Dynamic traffic
modeling uh is currently incomplete.
studies are underway and we will be able
to provide you with the information and
results of those studies and statistical
analyses once they've been completed.
End quote.
How can you as our elected officials
approve any project based on
inconsistent nonavailable data,
especially one that will have a negative
impact on the residents of our community
24 hours a day, 365 days a week? How can
you draft a traffic management plan with
non-existent data? Is there a traffic
management plan? Um, has a health
committee weighed in on the subject? And
if so, what have they had to say? And
why have we not been provided with that
information? Have you as our community
representatives held the community town
hall meeting like the one that you did
for the proposed casino? I'm not aware
of one. And if there was one, when was
it? And attended. Um,
one will conduct a community survey, a
community, I'm sorry, when you conduct a
community survey and engage the actual
residents of the community with the
impacts of this project. How can you
calibrate the impact of this project on
your our community with incomplete data
and non-existent data? How could you
vote on a project that will impact our
community with non-existent data?
Uh what is the role of community board
particularly community board 6? If you
do not listen to or engage with the
community, please do not undermine the
trust that we have in you. Please do not
vote on this proposal at this time. Wait
for the data to come in. Thank you. And
sir, we are we're not actually elected
and we did not hold it to the town hall
on the casino just to clarify. Thank
you.
and tell us about um let's have somebody
who's for the casino. I'd love the idea
of being
in the room. No one's for the casino.
I'm sorry. Let's for the bus way. And if
you two gentlemen would like to come
together, that would be fantastic.
Okay.
Start with your name and then you'll
have three minutes. All right. My name
is Jeff. Lifelong Manhattanite, I lived
here my entire life and like the
majority of Manhattan residents, I rely
on buses and trains. Um, I don't drive.
I honestly don't intend to. Um, one of
the great things about this city is the
fact that you can get bus train service
throughout most parts of the city that
you need to get to. Um, 34th Street is a
really component
part of that. Um, especially considering
that there's no subway line there. Like
the 34th Street cross town that exists
there now for transit riders is the only
option. And when that gets stuck, that
creates a a massive wall in the system
at large. Most of people most of the
people on 34th Street who are using the
Avenue are taking transit. Um it can
prevent for that matter of people who
live in the area don't own cars. They
are relying on mass transit.
This is in my opinion the most obvious
transportation solution you could do
here. like this is buzz racks represent
the vast majority of street users on
34th street. Um and it's not they're not
people from far field. These are people
within the city. These are New Yorkers
who use this day in day out. Um if you
do this bus proposal it will have an
immediate impact to get will in the best
possible way. Um it will be increasing
trip times as we saw with 14th street.
There will be relative increases. Uh
there'll be service boosts and it just
it was just a it's a no-brainer project
to me. Like this really needs to be
done. Like this needed to be done
yesterday. Honestly, like I've been on
34 street cross town buses that even
with the bus lanes are still at a crawl
because there simply isn't enough
priority. So I heavily encourage the
board to approve this project. Uh the
data already exists. the data is already
there to support this and I heavily
encourage the board to support it as
well because this is an obvious thing to
do. The fact that it's not done already
shocks me. Thank you.
All right. Thank you.
These two gentlemen are here. We'll get
We'll You'll have your turn next.
Thank you, community board saints, for
letting me speak in favor of the 34th
Street Bus. I am Chris Sanders and I
live on 35th Street. And I would like to
patronize the 34th Street buses more
than I currently do. 34th Street buses
are painfully slow, constantly blocked
by traffic. I like to use them to go to
B&H, Hudson Yard, Hudson path, and
various other places on like Third
Avenue to help a few friends there
also. Um, and time is life, and a fast,
efficient 34th Street bus would allow me
to get a piece of my life back. I
realize that some people in the
community and outside the community
would like to see Manhattan turned into
a museum, but Manhattan is a museum.
It's a city. A city is supposed to grow
and change and evolve. And D has
presented us with the data they've been
collecting since October 2024.
uh they stated that 99% of the cars
coming through the area are not staying
in the area. Only 1% of the cars
actually are patronizing a destination
in the area. Um and the proposed busway
uh on 34th Street, you know, it has to
work because there is no L train there.
You know, it doesn't have electrics that
14th Street has. um it can't be blocked
by traffic. I urge the community board 6
to give the people of New York City a
piece of their life back and to join
community boards four and five who both
support the 34th Street Busray. Thank
you again, community board 6, for
letting me speak. Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, Siri, you're up next and then
we're going to go to someone online.
Good evening. My name is David Sman. I
live in L Hill. Uh if you ask me if I
support
uh 34th Street Bus,
of course I do. What do you do? We all
want the buses to go more quickly. The
real question is, as the other journal
mentioned,
do you support the 34th Street busway if
it's going to send thousands of vehicles
onto the side streets?
Not at all.
A lot of people say, "Well, that end up
being a duplicate of things."
If that's true, that would be wonderful.
Where is the data? What is that traffic
analysis that I just heard was done
since October 2024
or June 2025.
discussing this without the data
I think is
you know putting the uh cart before the
horse or my new exact cliche
there uh do says there are 28,000 people
who use uh the 34th street bus there are
56,000 who live in Murray Hill who are
going to be impacted
there 79,500
vehicles
that go through the Midtown Tunnel every
day. There aren't too many blocks where
those vehicles can go. When you remove
34th,
logic says that they're going to go on
35th, 36, 37th, 38, 39. They can't go on
40th. Doesn't I mean they can't go in
the 40s because they're going to hit
Brian Park or uh Brady Central.
This is going to have
a real impact on our network.
I can tell you because I see the
traffic. The the streets are already
quiet.
And I wish I were wrong. If it turns
into 14th Street, that would be
wonderful. We We'd be celebrating. But
why can't D give us those numbers? What
is there to discuss before we know how
the entire neighborhood may be
decimated?
Thank you for listening.
See, we'll start now.
And again, if you can if you agree with
the previous speaker or someone who's
spoken before, please make your comments
short. We would appreciate that. We'll
take whoever's there. Let's just keep
going. Daniel Sutton, three minutes. You
may begin. Thank you. Um, I support the
34th Street busway. I think it would
improve Midtown traffic. It would
increase bus speeds, reduce the traffic
on the street, and it would make life
easier for everybody that uses that
corridor. So, just like on 14th Street,
there were a lot of predictions that
terrible things would happen, and none
of those things ended up happening. It
just made everything better. So, I
support the busway. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. All right. Um,
all right. Dylan, Dylan Kennedy,
you have three minutes beginning now.
Hi, my name is Dylan Kennedy. Uh, and
I'm going to try and keep this brief for
everyone. Uh, but I mostly just want to
share that I've worked uh right by 34th
and I've worked right by uh 18th Street
and the bus way just makes it a
spectacularly calmer, more peaceful
neighborhood. we I never saw any of the
the traffic spill over that people
warned about. Um and and just my
experience kind of working along both of
those different streets has taught me
that the busway makes it much more
pleasant, much more faster for
commuting. Um and just a much more
pleasant uh neighborly feel. Um, with
that, I'd also like to say uh I I very
much like the idea of um extending the
Third Avenue redesign uh all the way
down as uh I'm often frequently
traveling along that too and have
friends in the neighborhood. Um but
mostly from an element of just having a
nice more peaceful neighborhood with
faster bus speeds. uh and and from the
experience we've learned from doing this
to other similar streets, there isn't a
traffic nightmare and it just makes the
neighborhood so much better. So that's
why I urge you to support the busway.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. We'll move on to
Jessica Lavois.
Jessica Lavois. You have two minutes.
Thank you. Good evening. Uh my name is
Jessica Lavoy. I am a vice president of
the Murray Hill Neighborhood Association
and chair of its quality of life
committee. I'm here to express serious
concern about this board considering to
advance a 34th Street busway without
proper community engagement or real
data-driven planning. There's still no
traffic management plan. Our side
streets are already congested with
tunnel traffic. This plan would only
make it worse, adding pollution, noise,
and safety risks. This will affect our
most vulnerable, especially our seniors,
kids, and people with disabilities. Our
tunnel traffic will not magically
disappear. This is not 14th Street. 34th
is a major cross town corridor, a direct
link between two tunnels, and an
extension of I495. You cannot copy and
paste a plan meant for a completely
different traffic pattern. Another
important piece that is being
overlooked, the MTA's own website shows
that 34th Street buses, just looking at
the most recent month of April, are only
on average.3
miles per hour slower than the buses on
14th Street currently. Is that small
gain worth the serious disruption? Also,
why aren't we looking at the real issues
on 34th? We need more buses. We need to
enfor en enforce traffic rules, manage
ride share vehicles stopping in the
lanes, and fix the bottlenecks caused by
express buses turning at 6th Avenue. We
we really don't have enough buses on
34th Street. I take the bus every day. I
have waited over 20 minutes for a bus
only for it to take 9 minutes to get
across town. This could easily be about
service volume and not just speed. The
community survey that was done, it
wasn't even directed at residents. It
was done by stopping random pedestrians.
That is not meaningful input. It's not
how you reflect a neighborhood's voice.
The de the DOT has demonstrated that it
is highly capable of effectively
notifying the public. Whether it's
street fairs or parades, they put up
clear signage throughout the
neighborhood. In some cases, entire
blocks are lined with pink notices
drawing attention to these events. That
same level of visibility and outreach is
missing here. Research must represent
the full spectrum of community views.
The city says that the traffic is
already improved with congestion
pricing. So why are we forcing a
disruptive change now when the data we
have points to progress? This process
lacked transparency, planning, and
balance between transit goals and
neighborhood impact. We all do want
better transit, but it must be done
thoughtfully and responsibly. And I urge
you not to move forward until there is
real engagement, real data, and real
solutions. Thank you so much.
Next on the list is Charlie Todd.
Charlie Todd, uh, you have three
minutes. You may begin.
Thank you so much. Um, thank you so much
for your time, uh, tonight. I'll be very
brief. I know that there are so many
speakers tonight. Um, I am a resident of
community board 4, which also includes
34th Street, but I frequently visit the
whole 34th Street corridor, uh,
including the parts in CB6 to work, to
shop, to access transit, for doctor's
appointments. And I just want to express
my strong support for the busway
proposal. Uh, the 14th Street busway is
a huge success. I ride my bike on 13th
Street and 12th Street all the time, and
there's no spillover traffic. Those
streets are also very calm. Um, and I
think we deserve the same at 34th
Street. Unlike 14th Street, 34th Street
does not have a subway underneath it.
Uh, so the bus is all we got in terms of
cross town traffic. And I think it would
be such a big improvement for the
neighborhood and for uh, Midtown
Manhattan, both on the west side and the
east side, to have us connected by this
busway. I think it's time to prioritize
pedestrians and transit users and not
the minority of residents who use their
personal cars to get around or use their
personal cars to cut through from New
Jersey to Long Island. Uh, as a father
of two elementary school kids, I look
forward to a safer 34th Street with a
busway. Thank you so much for your time.
All right. Thank you. Next on the list
is David Lawrence. David Lawrence, you
have three minutes. I'm going to take
just 30 seconds. I want to echo what
Jessica outlined. Uh the issue is not
whether we want better bus service. The
question is on what basis are the
decisions going to be made. Are they
going to be made on a fully informed
basis with the necessary data with the
necessary planning and with the overall
quality of life? There is no question
that the people who visit the
neighborhood and the people who live in
the neighborhood deserve better bus
service. The question is what are the
best ways to achieve this? And I think
Jessica did an excellent job in
outlining outlining alternatives as well
as the need for the data. And just I'll
conclude on this point. It is not a
question of whether the city
representatives have the data that the
DOT has. The question is whether the DOT
has actually obtained and analyzed
sufficient data
and that is the missing gap here and
hopefully you will understand that as
part of the fiduciary obligations to the
neighborhood.
Thank you. Thank you. All right. Next on
the list is Paul Prickler. Mr. Prickler.
Three minutes. Thank you. My name is
Paul Crick. I use the cross town buses
all the time. I think every major cross
street up and down Manhattan, 14th,
23rd, 34th, 42nd, as far north and south
as you can go, should be a a busway like
14th Street. Imagine if you could live
five or six blocks away from anywhere in
Manhattan or a lot of Manhattan. You can
guaranteed to get across town in 10 15
minutes. It would transform how tens or
hundreds of thousands of people get
across Manhattan. make it a nicer,
quieter place. Which leads to the final
thing I'd like to say. 14th Street, it'd
be a nice quieter place like 14th
Street, which is much, much quieter now.
I went down to 14th Street the weekend
when it um became the bus way. The first
the first thing I noticed was you could
talk to someone, you still can across
the street because cars don't drown out
human conversation. And the second thing
was there was no Carmageddon. Everyone
was worried about this Armageddon that
didn't happen. Uh, and it seems like
it's magic. The cars just disappeared
away. And in in a sort of sense, they
did. I got to think afterwards, it's
simply the opposite of when they widen
the highway
and more cars come to fill it. Then you
have to widen it again. That's the
marginal users joining the the the race
there. It works the other way around as
well. It was the marginal users who
stopped using it. And the same will
happen again.
It becomes a better place for everyone.
So, I I'm strongly in support of this.
I'll also speak for for 10 seconds about
Third Avenue. Hugely in support, much
safer. I would love it to be extended.
Love the wide bike lane and love the
offset crossing. Please can we though
have concrete islands all the way up and
down third avenue. Thank you very much.
Okay. Uh, next is Miriam Fiser. Uh
Miriam Fischer, three minutes. Um can
you hear me? Yes. Okay. I'm from
community board 4, which as I think you
are doing a joint project with um four
and five. Um, one of the things I've
been getting on the radar is as we
improve bus the bus ways to think about
the bus stops which often have no seats
and no shelter from inclement weather
from 95 degree heat from snow and
community board 4 added it to their
letter. I was probably the catalyst, but
they are actually working on improving
the bus stops in the district and I
wanted to um again raise awareness to
community board 6 to get ask the DOT to
examine uh the bus stops, shelters,
seats and include that in um any any
request for uh the bus way. Thank you.
We'll go back to in person.
All right. Um, do we have people? We
don't know from our list if you're in
person or
but again, Andrew Hyatt, are you in the
room? Thank you. Okay, we'll go with
Andrew Hyatt.
Oh, thanks.
So, I I live I love athletes equidistant
between 14 and 34. So I was involved
also in the 14th Street discussions
the same thing because cardologically
we're happy to go somewhere but they do
just disappear and they did just
disappear. I I walked to work uh along
you know to solve the 14th street. I
don't see any real problems and I I kind
of hope for that good situation to
happen to 34th Street as well which to
my mind 14th Street really increase the
safety of that neighborhood or for
myself and for my my family and I I
think that's something that the
residents of this neighborhood also
would appreciate for them and their
families. Um, so I I hope that we could
consider that even though it seems like
the neighborhood will be flooded with
cars. This like we stop 14 street like
anytime you do this kind of uh this kind
of mitigation
car to lots of people to choose to do
something else
transport somewhere else whatever. So
this this happens and it will happen
again. I'm looking forward to what this
neighborhood collecting is going to make
it much much better. Thank you.
Scott Riiffken, are you in the room?
Scott Riiffken.
Uh
Richard Hart, are you in the room? He's
online.
Richard Hart, three minutes. Hi, how are
you? Or less. Yeah. Yes. Or less. My
name is Richard Hart. Thanks for
listening. Uh I live on uh 35th Street
between Park and Lexington. And I like
some others here am very nervous about
what this community board is thinking
and somewhat disheartened that it's
thinking about this without any data
whatsoever because the Department of
Transportation hasn't prepared anything.
I mean, that's obvious. And I just want
to cite for the committee one of the
things it wrote in its most recent 2025
statement of community needs. In this
document you write traffic in CD6 is a
major concern. We need a traffic study
and action plan to understand how
vehicular flow can improve with major
vehicular transit points like the 59th
Street Bridge, Queen Midtown Tunnel, and
FDR, plus sometimes all day avenue and
side street congestion. Solutions need
to be identified to allow better
movement for private cars, buses, bikes,
and pedestrians alike. By agreeing to
this 34th Street busway without any of
that data, it seems to me that there's
really no way for you to meet your duty
of care and duty to your constituents. I
understand that there's a lot of magical
thinking about how cars will just
disappear. But if they don't, then it's
the people that live in this
neighborhood that will be impacted, not
the bus riders or the bike riders that
like would like a slightly faster 34th
Street corridor. So, I would like the
board to really think about
understanding what the traffic
implications are for a third of its
community before uh agreeing to even
vote on this. And the one final thing I
will say is that traffic, noise and air
pollution models are not linear when
things get very busy. In fact, traffic
congestion eased only 12% uh in the
congestion zone in New York while noise
complaints declined 67%.
And I think you're going to put Murray
Hill right back in that hot seat if you
do this. Uh and I'm hoping you really
think carefully about waiting for the
data, waiting for a traffic analysis
that can be questioned and that can be
discussed before moving forward with
this proposal. Thank you.
All right, let's All right, Lily Seedman
Davis.
Uh, Lily Seedman Davis, you have three
minutes.
Thank you. Can you hear me? Yes. Oh,
terrific. So, while I fully support
improved public transit and reduced
congestion, this is not the answer. 34th
Street is a critical east-west link
between the Midtown and Lincoln tunnels.
Closing it to private vehicles won't
reduce congestion. It's simply
displacing it. Traffic will flood into
narrow residential streets which are
illequipped to handle the increase. This
plan doesn't make traffic vanish, it
shifts it. And when it gets repositioned
into residential neighborhoods, it chips
away at livability, safety, and
community integrity. We deserve better
than a solution that simply relocates
the problem. This is not opposition to
transit improvements, but to show but to
shortsighted planning that overlooks the
real world impact on residents. I urge
city leaders to consider more balanced
alternatives. Initiate comprehensive
traffic and environmental studies at a
minimum. In addition, where's
enforcement with ticketing cars that
block bus lanes? Add more buses to
address this. Think about under under um
the subway system in terms of building
something from that perspective. But
please reconsider this plan. We all want
a better city, but better must include
everyone. Thank you for listening and
considering the views of residents who
call Murray Hill home.
Okay, we have two more. Dana Freriedman.
Dana Freriedman, you have three minutes.
Hi. Um, how are you? Uh, my name is Dana
Freriedman. I live on 37th Street, which
is one of the um streets that exits out
of the tunnel. I fully support the bus
way. I want to just get that out of the
way. Um everyone seems very concerned
about um the traffic, but I just uh you
know, want to say that there's a
tendency of people to always imagine the
worst case scenario and it actually
never comes to fruition. We heard about
it with congestion pricing. Um we heard
about it with the 14th Street busway. We
heard about it when they wanted to take
the cars out of Central Park, when they
want to take the cars out of Prospect
Park. Everyone always cries wolf and I I
hear people saying that they want more
studies. I get the sense that people
wouldn't even believe the studies if it
showed, you know, that there wouldn't be
any um difference. And I want to just
end by saying that um the city, the
heartbeat of the city is public
transportation. And I feel like as a
city we have a responsibility to ensure
that we have the best public
transportation
uh you know possible. Um and you know
there are times where you know decades
from now where we all won't be here
anymore living in Murray Hill. There'll
be a community board that is turned over
you know four or five times. But there
could be a legacy of a busway, a status
quo, um, of that we are, you know,
putting these programs into place that
are going to benefit tens of thousands
of people and we should be supporting
that and not impeding progress. Cities
are about making progress and we should
be do everything we can to move forward.
Thank you. And I fully support the
busway.
We have some more people who would like
to speak in the room, but I highly
recommend consolidating your comments,
please. We're we're losing patience
here. So, um I think we'll follow down
through the list. We have a list here of
people who've signed up
information. How many more people How
many more people have we?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight. And two online. And two online.
It's
and unfortunately we're we're losing out
time but um so are we calling from the
list or we call from the list or we call
people not competitive.
Let's go ahead. Who's next on the list?
Okay. On the list uh Chris Sanders. Is
Chris Sanders in the room? Okay. Okay.
Uh, Max Mlaughlin. Is Max in the room?
Okay. And John Noble. Is John Noble in
the room? Okay. Basically in support of
the busway. Something to add that
something. Okay. Supports the bus way.
That's how to be brief. Yes. Yes. Samir
Lia, are you in the room? Okay. Charlton
Duza, are you in the room? Stacy Roush,
are you in the Rous? Are you in the
room? Okay. And here comes the
microphone. Three minutes or much less.
The other subject, everybody said where
they lived, which would explain why they
were interested in the subject. Lots of
people getting up saying, "I want the
bus way. Do you live here?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, let's
please let go.
The bigger problem is we don't have
enough of them. I sat and checked on
rush hour
and D and even 23. They had 45 buses on
the roof in each direction at every
single time I checked. We have two.
I have waited for the 34 bus at Park
Avenue for 21 minutes to go to 10th
Avenue. I don't know how much faster you
want it to be. I got there in 10
minutes. I also looked at the MTA's
website.
Right now, the 34 bus plots in at 5.9
miles an hour. Just so that you know,
14th Street, the A is 5.8 8 and the D is
6.1. So are we talking about a
hairspray?
No. Further 23 which has none of this
and doesn't close off to traffic has
also four or five buses and it moves at
6.1.
So, why are we trying to change
something when what I think we really
need is just more buses on our roots. I
think we should wait,
get more buses, and check back later
after the Dallas. Do not pass it now.
Living on 36 Street, I know what traffic
is. It goes into the tunnel. It comes
from New Jersey going out to the island
every day. It starts at 3 in the
afternoon and there are nights it goes
until 10:30.
The lights are red and when they block
Avenue, all they get is a lot of
honking. I don't want that back. Further
congestion pricing
and the cars going away. Honey, New York
is making an awful lot of money from it.
I don't think they've gone anywhere.
Good timing. Excellent timing. You're
done. Thank you. Thank you. Um, all
right. Two seconds on the list and
please. Okay. Kate F. They didn't give
their last name. Kate F. Are you in the
room here?
Three minutes. Yes, please. There you
go.
[Music]
that have not yet been brought up. And
I'll be fast. First, most of the people
in support of closing 31 streets of cars
don't live in the East 30s.
Sorry.
We are not streets.
The people coming from Jersey are never
going to give up their cars. Not only
that, I live on East 36 Street. I have a
front work seat to all traffic coming in
and out of the tunnel every day at rush
hour every week. We cannot handle more
traffic on these roads. We need 34th
Street to handle some of the capacity.
34th Street has five lanes, two of which
are buses. Those greener lanes are very
much necessary. I take the 34th Street
bus very often. I rely on it a lot and
it's actually fast. I'm impressed with
it. It takes 10 minutes to get from
Third Avenue to Hubs and Yards. What's
not fast is waiting for us
on that street. The problem is not
traffic.
They should not be. So we need traffic
enforcement and we need buses to run
off. Not only that,
we have hospitals here. We have medical
facilities. We have all the extra
patients that have to walk around the
corridor to find a taxi coming out of
the you know the cancer center. Like
this is this is just not the best way.
Faster buses. This is not the solution.
And the only way to get some real
accurate data would be by actually doing
this and seeing what happens. That's the
only way to get real data. At that
point, you know, they have to undo it if
it's not working out. And ambulances and
fire trucks and police cars trying to
come down 36 Street for emergencies,
trying to get through the traffic. The
cars don't want to move out of the way.
They're selfish. They move out of the
way for an ambulance. Just think how
that's going to be.
reports.
There's a mic problem. We can't hear
anything.
We'll get to it.
It's not fair. Our interest
in the interest of people
that would be impacted by this every
day. Great. Thank you. Perfect timing
and please um comments that are have not
been said before
or
Okay. Next on the list listing,
[Music]
there's something now wrong with the
total mic system. We can't hear
anything.
Sandy broke up. You broke up. Can you
hear me now? Yeah, that's much better.
Okay. Um I think what happens is the mic
will this mic will only register one
voice at a time. So, we'll try and keep
everyone orderly and speaking just one
at a time. But the mic that the people
are speaking on is really bad. We can't
hear that either. Okay. Um
what we can what we can do is um we'll
ask people to come to the front. Come to
the front. Yes. Okay. All right. Um
Nikquille Shrikumar in the room, please
come up. and just waiting in the wings.
Tessa Dunning, are you in the room?
Tessa Dunning. Okay. No. Um, Alex Wong
in the room. No, online. Okay. All
right. Well, um, please go ahead.
Microphone. No microphone. Just try and
project. That might solve it. Hi, I'm
Nick Hill. I'm a member of the Murray
Hill Neighborhood Association. Some of
my, uh, fellow neighborhood associate
members have already talked. Just wanted
to make some point just to address
concerns about uh I said as a
neighborhood association we our
president wrote a letter opposing the
the current iteration the current
iteration of the bus proposal. We I I
ride the M34 every day. I want a faster
I want a faster compute as well. We're
not against it. We just don't want to hy
want it to be a hasty process. I also
want to I think people have brought up
that the data is already there. I'm not
sure if we were at the beginning of the
meeting but we were asking for the data
and they said it was incomplete. So if
once the data is complete we will leave
any data showing and it's not just data
with simulation like you I'm a data
engineer living it's very easy to
simulate traffic if you have if you have
all data inputs we live in a world of AI
and it's like if you gave me a week I
could do it myself to be honest it's not
that hard to do we have you have city
funding I don't see why everybody in
this group is so easily trying to push
the proposal and also I kind of noticed
that everybody's
not to of course but everybody's talking
about 14 street obviously did a ton on
both sides this is all anecdotal data
actual data in terms of proposing it and
we can simulate that we have all the
data points we need just to be complete
um and as at the beginning of the
meeting state it not been done yet and
once it's there we we can all reconvene
again and as you go through the process
the main point is that the neighborhood
association and the M34 bus riders we
want to be on the same page like we are
all the same people like I take the bus
every day but I don't want like I just
don't want to do it in a hate manner.
Thank you.
Thank you. Who's next? Uh Jonathan
Miles, are you in the room?
Alexander Wong. Oh, Alexander Miles. We
switch back to online. Yeah.
Go ahead, Alexander. Sandy, use the mic.
Alexander.
Three minutes starting now.
He's unmuted. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry about
that. Um, sorry. I was on the wrong mic.
Um, hi. My name is Alexander Wong. I'm a
lifelong New Yorker. Um, and I'm a
resident of CB6 in Sutton Place. Uh, my
family had a uh coffee shop on 34th
Street for two and a half years uh in
2017. So, I I know uh I know that area
very well. Um I current I'm also a a
cyclist and a bus rider and a subway
rider and a pedestrian. Um and I am
strongly in support of the the bus way.
Um and I I don't think we should be um
you know not putting this forward
because we think that we need to support
um drivers uh commuting through uh
through 34th Street from New Jersey to
Long Island. And um I use cycle across
town a lot because uh because there I
don't think that a lot the 34th street
has the um speed and capacity to bring
me to work uh on time and I I I have to
avoid that kind of uh uh uh commute
through 34 street and I think that I
would really like to be able to use it
and I think that um for people who uh
are unable to bike and who need to rely
on public transit. I think that it's a
really powerful option. Uh and I'm
strongly in support of the 34th Street
busway. Thank you.
Uh
okay. Um Mikail Depre.
All right. Can you come up here, please?
After that will be Brit Smith. Already
spoken. And after that will be Marshall
butt.
Um
um I already actually
ride by the tunnel. So I be actually one
of the first impacted by
and I'm here to express my for
um yeah some people say we're not 14
street and we're not. That's fine. But
that doesn't mean we
um just to say 34 doesn't work for
anybody not just for riders for
students. It doesn't even work for cars.
So question to you why should we
maintain the status quo
and um provided extensive data
indicators. One key figure stands out
only 1% of vehicles have 34 street as
their final destination. So instead of
designing for that 1% let's focus on
majority the people who actually leave
work and corridor every day for this
neighborhood like me living on 34
street.
So I should commute.
Thank you.
Okay. Uh it looks like Marshall butt is
left. Uh Kate Hzer, are you in the room?
Kate. Okay. Uh Christopher
Christopher Rosario, are you in the
room? Okay. Um, Drew Robertson, are you
in the room? No. Should we go online?
Can I let one one last? Okay. Uh, Alex
Ivanak. Um, you have three minutes.
Hello. One last, please. Hi. Thank you
so much. My name is Alex Ivanac. I'm
part of the family that owns Villa
Bruier Restaurant. We're on 34th Street
between Park and Lexington Avenues.
We've been there for close to 44 45
years. So, we've seen 34th Street change
over many decades. And my only concern
is that the first time that I heard
about this bus proposal as a business
owner on the ground floor was when this
was passed last week. So, nobody came to
any businesses or any people who live in
the neighborhood from what I know to
even let us know about this proposal. It
was after the fact. And my biggest
concern also is the fact that people
keep saying 14th Street it's so great
blah blah blah. But the difference with
34th Street is that we have two major
tunnels. Two, not nothing. Two, not one,
but two. So, we have to figure out how
that will be diverted, how that will
affect. And you need to get local people
more. Like I said, we've been there a
long time. And the first time I heard
about this, nobody came to interview me.
Nobody came to interview my neighboring
business. And I think that this is
important to get more data regarding the
traffic patterns. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Who's next? Okay. Uh Drew
Robertson, are you in the room?
Uh Samuel Peter Panuio, are you in the
room? Oh, yes, we Yes, you are.
Okay. Where's the mic? Right here.
My name is Pete. I live on 36th Street
Park Avenue. I'd like to welcome all our
friends from turns all that here tonight
to voice their support. Um this this is
a sham.
You people are responsible for the fact
that none of this information was
transmitted to the community found out
about this.
Oh, transportation community
transportation was having a meeting
today. That's on you people. That's
something you need to address. So,
we're getting blindsided. They came on
here last week and had a very well time
bought out plan
34 but no test nothing. Oh, well that's
not a good answer. I don't care. People
say other things. You know what? Where
is that report? You're talking about
tens of thousands of cars that can get
diverted into the side street.
The people from DG don't even bother to
get off their ass and cannot look what's
going on over there right now. Make the
projects on 34th and uh I'm sorry, 35th
and Park, half the block, 36th and
Madison also has major uh construction.
Now to add insult to injury, Keith
Powers, who should be here and he's not,
he tweets the next day after the
transportation board with their alleged
vote last week. Keith Powers winds up
tweeting, "Hey, here's a new idea. How
about we shut Park Avenue down to one
lane in each direction on both sides of
Park Avenue?" So we already have an
untenable
situation and we get more and more ramp
down our throats. If they can blow that
past us, they would. You know what? Not
going to happen. People need to make
noise. Enough of this. And I have a
question for you people. Are there
people on this community board that are
actually members of transportation
alternatives?
Yes or no? You asking me? Yes or no? Oh,
they won. Who's on the transportation
committee? He was a transportation
listed as an activist. Okay, that's a
problem. Sir, why is that pertinent to
this discussion? You got you got and you
have an activist that voted last week.
He voted last week for the
transportation committee. That is wrong.
Please give me the mic. Will you please
stop pointing your finger at our sit
down? I'm not talking to you. I'm
speaking to her. Give me the mic. You're
welcome. Yes. Have a seat, sir. Thank
you. Okay. Nobody wants to hear that
stuff.
Disrespectful.
You think the community is not bad? Do
we do we have anyone else?
We are
the truth because you're
listening
to
sit down.
Sit down and be quiet. Please
both of you sit down.
Please sit down.
Please sit down. If we have anybody else
who wants to speak, please let's do it
now. Let's move forward. Who's next on
our list? Next on the list, uh Brian
Johnson.
Brian.
No, he's here. Okay, he's come up.
Brian Johnson. Is it Johnson? Next on
the list will be also Irma. Irma
Rosenblat.
Irma, please. And then Emily Jacabe.
And again, gravity is is much
appreciated. Absolutely.
Okay. My name is
East 32 for the last 27 years. And my
grandson attended the river school.
So I'm a native. I am in support of the
We we can't hear. Okay. Sorry.
And I'm a member of families.
Please put your mouth up to the mic.
Thank you. Yes, ma'am. Thank you. Thank
you.
So uh families for safe streets is a
group of people who have lost loved ones
to car crashes or survived crashes
themselves. We fight for change to make
our safe streets. Um I became a member
of families for safe streets in 2014
when my mother Ida was killed by a
speeding SUV. She was a strong
empathetic person who was deeply
involved in the community. She should be
here today fighting along us, but it's
not because our city prioritized the
movement of cars over her safety. I know
the pain, horror, and confusion caused
by the trauma of loss stemming from a
traffic crash. And I'm here today to ask
for your support building this busway to
improve the safety of this vital
corridor for all its users. Since the
implementation of the busway on 14th
Street, injurycausing crashes have gone
down by 42% and 84% of seniors reported
feeling safer on the streets than they
did before the changes were made. These
figures represent a remarkable
improvement in safety, and I think our
neighborhood deserves the same safety in
addition to the speedier commutes we
will experience with a bus web. I do not
like living in a community where I know
my neighbors are not safe on our
streets. Please support this common
sense project that will improve our
mobility and prevent lifealtering
trauma. Thank you for listening.
Um Emily Jacabe, are you still here?
Okay.
Jonathan Miles in the room or are you
online? Okay. Well, then let that let's
I think we've gotten everyone in the
room. Let's go online.
Um what is your name?
Uh Kate F was over there.
Okay. Kate F. Who didn't? Okay. All
right. All right.
Please, let's go online.
Okay, online. Brian fromitz,
uh, you have three minutes. All right.
Hey. Yeah, I'll be quick. Uh, I just
want to say that I work on 34th Street
and currently if I need to get across
town, I would take an Uber simply
because that is the most efficient way
to do so at the time. Um, but if there
was a busway, I would definitely be
considering that as my priority option.
And therefore, this would likely be
taking cars off the road, which people
are seemingly thinking that cars will
only be diverted to uh the side streets,
but in reality, I think a lot of cars
will come off the road and people would
choose to take the bus instead. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you,
Samir Levvenia.
Three minutes. Hi, thank you. I will
also be brief. Uh my name is Samir
Lvingia. I'm a frequent rider of all the
buses in New York City, including the
M34. Uh I'm also the vice chair of our
transportation committee over at
community board 5. And I'm asking that
you support this project. I believe and
it has been shown that our voices as
community boards are louder when we
speak as one which is the case or why we
are even have this item is because we
all wrote a letter together months ago
asking the DOT to to come and present a
busway to us so that way we could say
you know this is a good idea. We are
proactive and and that's why we're being
rewarded with um you know with this when
we speak with one voice. I think it
would be a shame to uh either not
comment on it or to say no at this
point. uh you know if we are going to
ask the DOT to do things and then they
do then we say oh just kidding we don't
actually want it uh why why would they
listen to us ever again so I I would
really encourage you to sign on and
support uh and lastly you know if you
don't weigh in on on this item now
you're not going to have a chance
because the implementation is supposed
to be in summer of this year and so I
really encourage you to take the
opportunity to weigh in today instead of
not having a voice at all thank you
Okay,
I think you're the last person. There's
one more. Sorry. Jonathan Miles,
this is Jonathan Miles. I'm online, but
I'll seed my time for uh I'm looking to
speak on another matter. Uh so, thank
you.
Okay. All right. I love a microphone. I
don't love going live.
Okay. So, two years ago, I bought my
first home. It's a Thank you. Thank you.
I'm a quick lady. I did it all in my
home. I don't need
a pull up, which is really tough to get
into. Yes, I'm very proud of myself. So,
I decided to get involved in my
community. So, that's what brings me
here today.
While I'm speaking on behalf of myself
only, I'd be remiss not to mention that
I'm also the secretary of Mars
Association. Now you might be think what
does the secretary do? One of my main
jobs is going after the inbox.
That means the emails of the people who
are sad and complain and have things on
their mind. It's me who has to answer.
And I do it very lovingly. But I have to
say it's usually a very easy task, but
this week my volunteer position became a
full-time job. I had to work from home
today just to get home.
But the emails are all concerns from
people about Murray Hill. They have
nowhere else to voice their concerns. So
they come to me. So these residents that
I now have personally connected with all
week.
They're confused about the busway. They
have questions about the busway. They're
opposed to the bus way.
You're a community board. So what I'm
asking is please represent the community
and listen to the people who call this
place home. Relieve the confusion,
answer the questions, and oppose voting
until more studies and community
outreach are done. It will make my job a
lot easier. Thank you. Thank you.
I think we have one last person,
Jonathan Miles.
All right, Jonathan Miles. Three
minutes. I I'm online. I'm primarily
speaking on another item, so I'll seed
my time on this one. It's always the
last meeting. Are you for or against?
I am for the busway. Uh strongly in
support and I take umbrage on behalf of
all the other supporting citizens of
Murray Hill. Uh that it's implied that
there's not a strong presence in the
room and online in favor.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay.
No, you've already spoke. We're done.
We're done. Um, sorry. The minutes from
the March 14th full board meeting were
distributed to board members. If there's
no objection, we will adopt the minutes
as drafted. If you if you object, raise
your hand. Seeing no objections, the
minutes from the May 14th full board
meeting are adopted. They will soon be
available on the CB6 website. My report,
we are planning on getting together at
the Sutton Place Park Celebration in Man
for Manhattan Hinge July 11th at 6.
Watch your email. That's it. Uh,
district manager Jesus Perez will now
give a report waved.
Disman will give our report treasures
report. I may make it very short. You'll
find the whole report in the minutes,
but I just wanted to comment on two
numbers for community board's budget uh
for the fiscal year and we're coming to
the end of the fiscal year was $612,04.
We've encumbered already 400,048
and 421.
So for the remaining month that we have
left, we have about $20,000 left. We're
looking at our personal services because
the mayor did a cost of living. We don't
have the funds for it yet. So this is a
different year. We really will not be
turning back money, but just covering
our budget as it is. and the more
details will be in the minutes.
Okay, thank you. We've now arrived at
our committee reports and resolutions. A
reminder that the same rules stated at
the beginning of the meeting apply.
Members of the public, please note that
during this section of the meeting, we
only recognize questions from members of
the board. So, the digital ballot was
sent to all members. Select your name,
select your vote on each resolution
that's presented. Don't don't submit it
till the end of the meeting. Um
um remember reminder that if you choose
to abstain that's usually a negative
vote. The final vote counts will be
announced after the second roll call.
All right. If any anything is unclear
please raise your hand and we can help.
First up is parks, landmarks and
cultural affairs. Sarah Whittington,
Neil, and I would just like to inform
you all that the New York City pools are
open June 27
as even
there.
Yes.
Ster, chair of public safety and
sanitation.
Frank, I was asked to consolidate my
resolence. It's not my skill.
But the resolution that we are
presenting tonight is about discovery,
which um is is essentially in this
context um in criminal law about the
prosecutor giving the defendant uh the
evidence that they possess. Uh the rules
of discovery are not trivial
technicalities.
about the rights of criminals. It's
about detecting innocent people. His mic
went out. Evidence is what's mostly
turn on. And if the process goes wrong,
innocent people,
hold it close. Yeah. If the process goes
wrong, innocent people uh end up uh um
basically in prison. Uh so uh you end up
creating additional victims. You have
the victim of the original crime. Now
you have the victim of the state and yet
the um the actual perpetrator continues
to go free. So it's very important that
evidence be exchanged in order for in
a couple of proposals that are favored
by the Manhattan District Attorney which
would make the system work better. uh
and we oppose them amendments that were
put forth by the governor uh who
apparently wants to buff her um tough
armed crime credentials. Um but the
proposals would foster some injustices.
Um I I just want to add that this is not
a seat of defense resolution. The
committee met for two consecutive months
with both the district attorney of of
Manhattan and the legal aid society.
They both presented um forceful,
passionate, um intelligent remarks. Um
we heard their arguments and we dug into
this. So this is um this is a complex
issue that and a considered decision. Uh
if anyone has questions, I will attempt
to answer them
and if there's not, we can move over.
Okay, let's um please mark your digital
val. And while you're doing that, uh
Steu's going to give his report. Just
pardon me, just for um clarity. Um can I
move that we vote? Can I call the Oh,
sure. Call the question. And can we have
a second? Second. Thank you.
Stu, you have a report? I wave there.
Oh, okay. All right,
next up we have business affairs and
licensing. Anton Mhler is our chair.
Bundle
the resolutions that came out of this
meeting
we had a couple weeks ago was more than
four hours. So, so 3 hours will be here.
Item A
item A resolution with objection
for a new cannabis application for
retail dispensary license for Danny
Kogan. Uh the committee uh had
objection because Mr. go into being
involved to show up to make any
presentation and he didn't provide his
work. So if he's not interested in doing
that, we're not interested in supporting
his application.
Do I have a solution to
bundle? Can we bundle? Yes. No, just
just as it's
okay. So the question follow the
question. All right. So okay
resolution
I think they want to bundle everything.
They can't. Sorry. Okay, please. All
right.
Uh item B resolution in favor of
candidates NYC.
Um
yeah, the applicant did abide by all the
rules from uh control board and the
presentation was um
appropriate and
we filed resolution. judgement
this application
club.
Okay. Okay. Now I like the motion C
all the way to P.
These are resolutions
supporting sidewalk cafe applications
for the restaurants indicated.
We had a lot of problems with them. They
did support uh they did provide us with
their dot applications which are all
appropriate and uh as the do has
requested the resolutions we made are
for approval not for recommendation.
So I'd like to move a question one to
bundle and two to vote on those items
through item.
So C through P. Yeah.
Okay. RMS I'd like also
uh these are modifications
um
of their um
applications for the side cafes. Um we
did approve these modifications
for um
cafe or bowl. Um we asked them to modify
the schematic
uh regarding their seller door
or the ugly coyote.
Uh we asked them modify their
application to indicate the correct
sidewalk width
so that there was clear pedestrian pamp
and for
same thing modify their schematics for
the dot to recognize the exact width of
the sidewalk.
Do I hear a question? Question. Second.
Okay. Okay.
Like the bundle
T, U, and D.
These are all against Sidewalk Cafe
applications.
Uh we have no wishes with them and we
did recommend approval.
Question. Question. Second. Okay.
All right. Uh W next.
These are alterations request for liquor
licenses since
um these two applicants
uh have received information from the do
who have sidewalk cafes.
And in order to serve liquor, you must
get an alteration
from the SLA. Uh we have no wish for
that. I'd like to call the questions on
WX. Question.
Okay.
Um starting with Y
H.
Um,
these are all retro license requests. No
application and temporary
retail permits. We've reviewed every
single one of them. None of them have
had any issues. None of them had any
complaints on their premises and they
were all approved by the business
affairs committee. Would somebody call a
question?
Second.
I'm sorry
[Music]
objection
application temporary brief permit for
wine and beer and sire license to find
193rd Avenue
South as a no show did submit the
questionnaire
and the committee felt there was not
enough interest to do that we don't have
enough interest to take their no
objection. So we object to their new
application.
All the question.
Okay.
Last but not least, JJ resolution
requiring application temporary retail
permit for on purposes liquor license
for and for Gy Park Hotel.
Now
obviously we've heard a lot of
leaders today who are against
um we also have been in contact with
both parties since the bulk met some
weeks ago and
uh we've had some discussions at the
U am ourselves and we do have a
resolution
that's differs slightly from what we
originally submitted to the board last
month. And these uh changes are
indicated in red on the um resolution
and uh given what we've heard tonight
for and against
um I'd like to call the question
to have the
members of the board
vote for this for audience.
Second uh we have question when sorry we
have one hand raised Sandra. Yeah. Um
I'm sorry I was going to speak as a
committee uh a community member but I
realize I couldn't. Uh I did want to I
have various points but I know we are
exhausted. Uh but one was really
important. The one of the ways we ended
the discussion last time was that the
developer was supposed to meet with the
community members. They did not do that.
They did not reach out to the community
and I you would have a as as much as it
was tonight you'd have had an even much
larger push back against that was an act
of bad faith. The person who said these
folks act under the radar screen really
inaccurate
I I we don't want to have that
discussion. I just want to make the
point there was never a notice sent out
to the community at all. Nobody in my
building which has like 40 apartments
has any idea of what's going on. That
was went in complete um uh opposition to
what we had decided was what these folks
needed to do. That needs to be on the
table so you understand that was
duplicitous in my mind. They could have
met with five people. They never reached
out to the community. I want you folks
to know that. Okay.
Um I think I mean I can help clarify
this condition which I believe that um
Sandre left off as saying that um it was
a very small portion of the community
that was actually that met with the
applicant. No, that's not what I'm
saying. I'm saying they never reached
out to the community. The deal was they
were going to let the community know
what was going on. They never did that.
Right. So, they may have reached out to
a couple people, but they never got, if
you're going to talk about a community,
and this is a community board, the
community had a right to know what was
going on, and they do not know.
We're not allowed to speak or how do you
speak? We're not allowed. We're not Yes,
we're not allowed to speak. We only take
questions and comments from people on
the board. But I um I think we have to
be clear that the applicant did believe
they were talking to representatives of
the community. It may not have been the
full community according to some of our
definitions, but um I think they felt
that they were reaching out as we
requested. Okay. That was Yeah. But I'm
saying that experience as a community
member that did not happen and I feel
that the community board needs to know
that. Yes.
Okay. All right. Sorry. Here
the appointed community board six member
and my first meeting was last month when
this was
I do recall there was accountability on
both sides of the equation to meet
separately separate from the bulk
meeting separate from the full board. So
I just want to make that be on record
that that was the advice given that we
were hardressed as a full board to vote
on last month and that was the
accountability on both sides. So not
just on the owner it was also the
community. So I just want to make sure
that it's put in the notes. Right. And I
believe you'll see that in our
modification. We do acknowledge that
there was as we requested there was me
there were meetings between what we
understood to be the community and the
applicant.
All right. I think the question's been
called. Please let's vote on your
ballot. While that's going on, Anton, do
you have a uh do you have a report?
And uh how many how many people on the
June agenda? That's that's our next um
Okay, our next up we have uh Gabe Tupo
is the chair of the Landerson
Waterfront.
Okay, we have two quick family-friendly
non-controversial
phase two is going to require the
Patrick Brown walk to be closed. So, we
are asking that some additional work be
added to the scope of work. Uh, Patrick
Brown walk has kind of decayed
trellises, uneven bricks, there's
graffiti, there's missing trash cans,
there's missing benches. Uh, we're
asking for all that to be remedied and
graffiti-free surfacing to be added.
Any questions? Nope. Call the question.
Call the second. Okay. There since
there's no objection, we'll now vote on
the resolution. Please mark the digital
ballot.
Okay.
We're asking to submit written testimony
regarding the Freedom Plaza Casino,
asking them to vastly expand the design,
scope of work in the environmental
impact study. This is a more fleshed out
version of verbal testimony that I
already gave. We're going to challenge
them on a number of points to do a
larger environmental impact study. The
original one only wanted to look in a
quarter mile. Uh we want them to
incorporate socioeconomic conditions,
including things like gambling addiction
and the prevalence of pawn shops near
casinos. We asked them to look much
deeper into traffic. The original
proposal was grossly active but only
looking at 11 intersections. We want to
look at a lot of things including access
of first a hospitals.
Uh we're concerned that their cooling
method is going to be very disruptive.
The east river ecosystem. We're worried
about nor there's a a lot of interesting
stuff. This resolution will give us the
right to submit that testimony. Thank
you. Any questions?
Call questions. Thank
Okay, please please please vote on on on
the resolution and mark your digital
ballot. Next up, we have Steve Perez who
is currently vice chair of budget and
governmental affairs.
Resolutions from
Okay,
see question second. All right, please
vote on the resolution and mark your
digital ballot.
Okay. Um that's for both both of the
resolutions. Okay. And um waving the
report. So next up we're going to
transportation which is Jason from
chair.
Thank you.
Our first resolution up. We are
discussing the 30 points bus. Uh DT
presented to the committee a detailed
datadriven plan to improve bus speeds on
34th Street uh that would benefit 28,000
members of our community where the bus
uh is on that street daily and dozens of
others who move across the corridor each
day. We listened to many members of the
community's feedback. No new information
was raised today that was not raised
previously during the committee. The
committee voted unanimously to recommend
that we move forward with this plan. I
want to address a call from the public
session to delay the decision. Uh I
believe we should consider the following
in considering the speed at which this
project moves forward. Number one, level
of impact. Number two, degree of
certainty.
Number three, risk of inaction or delay.
And number four, risk of getting it
wrong. One, level of impact. There's a
high level of impact. There are 28,000
community members who ride the bus on
the corridor daily. There is no subway
alerting the corridor and buses of the
only way across town. Two degree of 30
ft although high the 14th street way
resulted in a 34% improvement in bus and
no negative impact to neighboring
streets or businesses. No study or model
can provide data with 100% certainty.
Real world data such as this offers a
high level of confidence and a higher
level than any model can provide. Number
three, risk in action. Also, highly
continue. If we fail to act, we will
continue to fail the 28,000 members of
our community who ride the bus on 34th
Street on buses that travel at 3 to 5
miles per hour during rush hour. We will
also continue to fail needs of others
who would take the bus but now walk or
take taxis or drive due to unreliable
and slow bus service. And number four,
risk of getting it wrong. This is slow.
The proposed bus the proposed busy will
be a quick be able to be quickly
implemented and at low cost. The
implementation will be primarily paint
and street lines. If the project is a
failure unexpectedly despite the
available data that we have, it can be
easily reversed.
And thank you. We'll take questions.
Rich.
Yep.
I just speak about this that I think I'm
going to ask the permission of the group
to call a question at this point.
Second. Great. Okay. Um seeing
um if there's no objection, we will now
vote on the resolution. Please mark your
digital ballot.
There is objection.
Oh, sorry. U the question was called
and seconded.
No, I I objected I object the whole the
whole plan.
I I'm I'm sorry. You want to Can I lend
a comment? Can I lend a comment?
Um sure. We'll let you we'll let you
comment and then we'll we'll vote. Okay,
great. Okay. So, I just want to mention
um watching this meeting last week, uh
the community did not have a chance at
all because your minds were made up
before the meeting even began. And
again, when did the comm when did you
reach out to the to the committee? When
did you reach out to the community? When
did the agency reach out to the
community? When did the electives reach
out to the community? As per the DOT,
you know, Rachel's own words, 34th
Street is not like 14th Street. It is
very unique and it is a very important
corridor. There is still monitor
monitoring to see if this would work.
data that should have been provided at
this juncture still unanswered. But
really what I'm concerned about mostly
is the optics of your committee that it
doesn't look good. The way you
manipulated and rushed through the
meeting, rushed through the resolution
to get this to the full board meeting
before the break before the community
engagement before the community had a
chance to do due diligence before
research is complete. So it begs the
question, what is the role of the
community board when you have not
engaged in the community? So this whole
manipulative meeting that you had last
week really begs the question. So, you
know, it doesn't it does not look good
on community board 6. And so I I ask
that people reconsider this until we
have more information, please. until we
I'm not against faster transportation
from one end to the other, but this is
clearly a rush job and it it does not
look good on us. Thank you. Um well, and
we have Liz Liz Burr also has her hand
on. Yeah, I just had a couple of
questions. It was mostly about um on the
report from the DOT it they mentioned
that there'll be a traffic analysis
report that will handle dynamic traffic
modeling and so I don't know if we know
an ETA or did they already deliver that
to us because it's just that they would
re provide us results when it's done but
I don't and um we have we've been
speaking with the DOT and they let us
know that there will be a report they
assume by the end of the month and that
they will make a separate presentation
to the Murray Hill Neighborhood
Association that we are able to attend
as well. Okay. But there will be a pres
a specific presentation made to the
Murray Hill Neighborhood Association.
Okay. Thank you.
And Jason, you'd like to respond to uh
just very briefly. Uh so we've been
discussing a 30.3 buzzway for at least a
year. In June 2024, we uh first passed a
resolution asking for a busway on 34th
Street. Uh several months ago, we passed
a resolution unanimously and the board
approving PFD's uh or sorry uh asking
specifically for a bus way after GFD
presented a number of options for 34th
Street. Uh so there was ample
opportunity for the community and the
community board to object. There has no
objection during there's one vote in
objection to the first resolution we
passed. The second resolution passed
unanimously. No members of the community
came to any of our committee meetings
prior to the last week to fight an
extensive opportunity for public
right and you're still lacking a ton of
data that you have don't have and they
even admitted themselves it's ongoing
it's ongoing it's not conclusive that it
even works
all that
anyway
I'm Sorry, we couldn't hear what you
were saying, Michael. And do you have a
question? No, I was just saying that,
you know, you make these decisions on
inconclusive
uh analytics that they've admitted they
do not have. It's ongoing work. You had
a briefing in March and you decided to
do this. I mean, you're not talking to
the the people that live right in Murray
Hill. You're not talking to them
obviously because people have spoken
about that and missing this this
information.
So Sandy, the question has been called
this massive project that you're making
a decision on. Anyway, I'm done. Thank
you, Michael, for your comments and we
will proceed to vote. The question has
been called.
Okay, moving on to the next item on the
agenda for transportation. Uh the next
is a uh proposal from the department of
transportation to implement a double
best way on the southern portion of
Madison Avenue
only I think three or four blocks of
extension on 34th Street. We saw
dependent presucing
place. Um this is a open street that
existed in the last four years. We're
recommending that we continue to allow
the open street. Follow the question.
All right. We'll now vote on the
resolution. Please mark a digital
ballot.
All right. Next up, um, is the implement
implementation
of a double bus lane on Madison Avenue
between East 23rd Street and East 42nd
Street.
Following the question. All right.
Please. Second. Second. Let's proceed to
vote.
Um this is the next one is the complete
street redesign of third avenue.
Yeah. So, so yeah, lastly from
we have a resision requesting that the
city council passes legislation to
require Wait,
sorry. I'm so sorry.
I'm not sure everybody's clear. the
resolution in support of a complete
street redesign on Third Avenue from
24th Street to 59th Street in Manhattan.
We have been asking for a bike lane on
Third Avenue for many years. We
commissioned the study for bike lane on
Third Avenue. DOT has finally presented
a bike lane for Third Avenue within our
district. It's a continuation of the
bike lane uh on Third Avenue that exists
on the upper east side just outside of
our district. And are there any
questions? Oh, question. Second. Second.
And unfortunately, um, Jonathan Miles,
who was very kindly seating his time,
actually wanted to talk about this next
issue. So, if we don't mind, we'll like
to give him his three minutes. Jonathan,
please go ahead.
Thanks very much to everybody for
permitting me the time here. Uh, and I
know it's been a long meeting, so I'll
give the very brief version of it. Uh,
I'm a lawyer, a cyclist, and a
pedestrian in District 6, and I'm
speaking in favor of the resolution
calling upon the New York City Council
to enact legislation to mandate that
cyclist traffic violations be treated as
noncriminal sums. Uh, I share the
frustration with cyclists traveling in
the wrong direction, riding on
sidewalks, and uh, running red lights.
They're all behaviors that obstruct
others that have the uh, right of way.
But criminalization is not the answer.
Proper enforcement and tickets uh, is
the answer. Uh, a few supporting facts.
First, ebikes cause less than 0.5% of
pedestrian injuries. Second,
criminalization would expose a
vulnerable New York City worker
population to ICE enforcement, which
we've seen recently at judicial hearings
and even naturalization proceedings. And
lastly, uh, criminalization would pull
police attention from the causes of
99.5% of pedestrian injuries as well as
other public safety concerns. As
criminal matters require more police
time than simp simple traffic citations,
police should be focused on true risk to
safety and more significant nuisances
like illegally parked cars blocking
traffic uh and blocking visibility uh as
well as the enforcement of traffic to
keep car traffic flowing uh in our busy
intersections in this district. Thanks
very much.
Yes. All right. Um if
have we called this question yet? Thank
you. Please mark your ballots.
Thank you.
All right. Health and environment Rub
Kakad chair. I'm gonna I'm going to make
it really really brief. Uh we have a
meeting tomorrow. Uh you at the start of
the meeting you heard from Belleview. Uh
tomorrow we're going to hear from MSBI
uh about the new urgent care center that
they've opened up. And that's it. Great.
Thank you. Uh, housing and homelessness,
Alec Malik Militi is waving up here.
Youth and education, Joan Keller. John
Keller's waving as well. Board members,
if you have any old or new business to
state, please raise your hands. Submit
your ballots, please. All right. And
then Justin will conduct the second roll
call.
inform
that we have an extensive website every
meeting every
Yeah, we got you. David Woods.
See you online. David. Oh, David. Can
you hear us?
Which David? I'm here. David Woods. Oh,
no. David will be here. David Woods is
here as an attendee.
Okay, we'll get to him later. And he's
having difficulties.
I'm here.
David Woods.
Sarah.
Okay.
James
Gabriel
Mark Thompson present
present. Uh, does somebody want to take
my vote? Brendan, yes, I will. Excuse
me. It's Larry Sh. I I couldn't unmute.
I'm here.
We haven't gotten to you yet. Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Yes. You ready? Yep. Okay. Um
on on on number two, a abstain
on three
on bulk. Now bulk
A is yes, B is no. And from C to double
J is yes.
Okay. Okay. On land use uh A and B. Yes.
Okay. On on um business uh and
government affairs A is no, B is
abstain.
And on transportation,
A is abstain, B is yes, C and D are
abstain, and E is no.
So C and D are abstain. Correct. And E
is no. Yes. Correct. A A A is abstain. B
is yes. C and D are abstain. And E is
no. Okay. Um I will work on submitting
your ballot. Thank you. Okay. So we
don't delay.
pres
not here. And again, not here. Lauren
Sher,
uh, I'm here and I'm happy to report
that they're going to discharge me
tonight. So, I'll be with back with the
living.
Feel better, Larry. Better, Larry. Thank
you so much. Wish I could have been
there.
Not here. Will Perry present. Steven TZ
Pel present.
Kevin O'Keefe not here and not here.
Richard Miz present. Alec Mill here.
Sandra McKe present. Anton present.
David Levy present.
Sandra Leth here.
Atlanta present.
Keani not here.
Kennedy
Sean.
Kak here.
Paige Judge present.
A present.
Gloria
present.
Justin,
Eric Goldberg,
present.
Jason, present.
Freeman, present. Robert Fairfield,
not here. May
I
present?
Stuart Deser
here. Jim Collins. Yeah.
Winsburg present.
Daniel Bernste
not here. Mar
not here.
Not here.
is
what
Arias areas until the bitter end
okay
just just before we read out the results
I I did want to let everyone know that
we do have a website that announces all
of our meetings we do send out a blog
And if you are on our our email list,
there is something that goes out once a
week that announces meetings and the
agendas. So I highly recommend everybody
sign up for our email. Um and then
you'll be, you know, made aware of any
of these meetings that you feel are
important. The agenda is always the
agenda is online. We post it ahead. It's
in the emails and it's in the email and
it's in the newsletters in full written
by fantastic staff but we are glad that
so many people have participated and uh
it's good to know that you know voices
feel they can come and speak to us.
Okay, we're tallying up.
Um, I presume you don't want me to uh
you don't want me to site 50 diff almost
50 different reszos. So, I'm going to
summarize them all.
Few
more seconds.
[Music]
It's cold. Okay. I just want to
for those who are interest uh
Yes.
Um all other res to green JJ uh pass.
Green JJ was the grand park one. It
passed 29 in favor opposed for
abstensions.
Uh all the other bulk resolutions passed
um overwhelmingly. You're echoing. I'm
sorry. All the other bulk resolutions
passed overwhelmingly.
As far as any other resolution,
um all the budget resolutions passed,
transportation,
the one uh on um that was the 34 city
busway that passed 31 in favor
of every transportation resolution have
to overcome. So everything is passed up.
I do want to reiterate that the DFT did
say that they would meet with the Murray
Hill Neighborhood Association.
So before this gets implemented, you
will have your chance to speak with the
DOT and look at any data that they have
and sign up for the website. And please
sign up for the website so that you'll
know any of the upcoming meetings. Thank
you.
Oh. Oh. Seeing no objections, the
meeting is at 10:20.